[Musique]
et bonjour à tous salut Kevin j'espère
que tu vas bien
ouais je vais très bien stouf salut à
tous on est reparti c'est la finale
stouf c'est la finale du speed ch
Championship féminent avec ouan avec les
Blancs qui est ouvert sur une italienne
contre Harik hier qui nous a régalé dans
un match contre
Catarina elle a été audessus tout le
long du match c'était la la surprise
comme tu l'as dit hier et et maintenant
est-ce qu'elle pourrait faire pareil
contre an pourquoi pas parce que IFAN on
a vu qu'à ces Caden là il y avait quand
même pas mal de Varian donc elle est
elle est bien chaude sans doute après ça
ça perve d'IER et elle peut elle peut
envoyer du lourd c'est ça ouais donc le
match à 13h donc je sais pas quelle
heure il est en en Chine
Kevin j'ai pas j'ai pas
é moi non plus mais mais voilà CTA fait
exprès parce que en Chine là je pense
c'est déjà déjà la soirée et je me
souviens à l'époque les tournois quand
jou d les gros tournois et à l'époque c
un cauchemar quoi il jouit à 3h du matin
c'était pas pas viable et donc du coup
elle a dit à la base on devait jouer on
devaitnonc pour la finale mais
finalement quand a gagné la demiinale C
résard mais bon c'est logique c'est
normal ça changé le jour ça devait être
le lundi puis la demifinale a déjà eu
lieu le mardi donc c'était pas mal que
ce mercredi soit trouvé et en Inde je
crois qu'il est 4h30 de moins que chez
nous C donc ça va tu vois c'est ouis
c'est bien tout le matin pense
que n en effet oui j'ai j'ai un problème
entre les nom je
désoléé de caméas sauf que là les blancs
ah faire une petite erreur je te
remercie
prof ça commence bien j' les caméras
bien il me semble je me suis PL tout à
l'heure céta inversé et en fait
réinversé non gut bon a a a j'ai
peut-être fait n'importe
quoi bon c'est pas trop grave vous voyez
en tout cas une une italienne à peu près
tu as réussi à changer très rapidement
non changé de scène oua malheureusement
Pasut
ok c'est bon au niveau des caméras prof
mais attention
est quand même du mauvais
côtéurelle est noir dans cette partie
voilà on on a maintenant blanc qui est
en
basérifier discrtement que tout soit bon
maintenant
c'est et là c'est
bon
elle est là elle est là Yume salut à toi
voilà c'est bon salut
yum en plus il est en bleu tu vois comme
l'Argentine il v pas comprendre y
pourquoi on le tra
d'argentin alors fou B3 a été joué donc
c'est assez classique ce qui se passe
ici pour D4 prochainement sans doute
avec les les blancsin et on voit que
c'est
vraiment symétrique tu penses que que
olifan elle s un peu préparée par
rapport au parti qu'elle a pu voir hier
de harika contre Katharina Lano oui
c'est possible après elle a joué
l'italienne alors que hier on a vu des
Espagnols donc finalement elle a juste
peut-être checker la database
et et regarder ce qu'elle pouvait jouer
mais pour l'instant elle s'est pas
appuyé sur le match d'hier
vraisemblablement puisqueune italienne
bon on sait juste que Harik est capable
de jouer une Française et
majoritairement elle a joué au 5 hier
ouais j'ai pas j'ai pas vu le début on
va juste refaire très très vite standard
avec l'ancien coup à 6 parce que
maintenant il a il y a pas mal de de
lignes avec a 5 ok oui elle a pas joué
l'esagnool comme le gros débat d'hier en
fait voilà exactement peut-être qu'elle
a pas eu envie de checker ou peut-être
que juste on va voir peutre qu'elle
préfère l'italienne enfin il y a pas mal
de de spéculations poss possible on voit
ce plan he des des deux joueuses
vraiment de de de mettre le cavalier B1
en G3 pour les petits euh les petits
trics sur les
lois c'est ça et euh donc ok donc D5
donc là il y a souvent des idées avec
pris et cavalier prend le 5 à surveiller
aussi oui oui c'est c'est logique hop
c'est logique de de prendre en D5 et là
c'est
toujours la séquence classique avec D4
ouais alors juste expliquer trs
dangereux expliqu pouroi c'est chaud
tout croqué sans
douteend fa regarder F F2
ou quand
mêmeématique de
manger donc donc voil
j le et on met un petit c
devant
symétriquee on a la tour en premier qui
est quand vraiment pénible en c'est un
petit truc évidemment mais bah il faut
c'est positions qui sont pas faciles
finalement à jouer avec les Noirs t
d'ailleurs c'est normal al est-ce que on
peut jouer tour prend dame prend on peut
jouer contre contre un pion isolé avec F
prend D5 ouais c'est un truc intéressant
donc souvent on vous dit que les fous
sont très importants mais quand on a un
P isolé comm comme ça ça peut vraiment
jouer en plus pour le mauvais coup hein
et cetera donc fou 3 éventuellement C
position échanger les fous ça reste une
bonne affaire ce matin j'ai eu un cours
avec un élève qui n regarde peut-être
d'ailleurs je sais pas s'il est là il a
pas échangé les fous il est parti avec
son fou en F4 G3 je lui dis non c'est
pas comme ça qu'on joue contre unol
ouais ouais tout à fait mais mais voilà
il changer les fous en tout cas changer
les pièces qui qui viendra en B8
d'ailleurs le fou noir pour pas les
changer j'ai j'ai un problème avec mon
fou distinctif de case blanche avec les
Noirs parce que je suis le seul à avoir
le fou de case blanche et c'est pas
facile de le valoriser d'ailleurs on va
peut-être voir arriver fou D7 dans cette
position pour au moins taper le pion A4
ouais pour développer aussi mais c'est
vrai que sur généralement ben en fait il
a pas de bon case quoi c'est ce fou qui
va très souvent d'ailleurs même défendre
le pion D5 une fois qu'on aura réussi à
l'attaquer donc est-ce que là on va
jouer un coup du style euh à 5
peut-être un peu ça donne des GES un peu
au fou quand même diras mais c'est pas
facile de prendre une décision par
rapport à ça va fallir être assez rapide
et d'ailleurs sououf on peut préciser
que la cadence est légèrement différente
de ce qu'on a pu connaître en
demi-finale vous voyez que au lieu des
75 minutes de 5 + 1 on a le droit à 90
minutes de 5 + 1 c'est le le le format
de l'ancien speed chess on va dire que
l'on retrouve qui est un peu plus long
que les matchs des demi-finales Souf
c'est ça c'est ça donc on là on a 90
minutes euh au lieu de 75 qui était euh
jusque- là bon tous les matchs hein
jusque jusqu'à la finale euh en 5 + 1 en
3 + 1 on a 1h au lieu de 50 minutes et
en 3 + 1 on a une demi-heure au lie de
25 minutes bien sûr donc voilà en gros
ça donne à peu près une partie en plus
dans chaque oui c'est ça on aura 3h30 de
match au de 3h 3h15 quoi un peu plus de
3h30 3h 45 voilà maximum au lieu de 3h15
c'est long pour les joueus parce que
c'est des formats qui sont hyper
exigeants où bah les groses bêtises
tactiqu peuvent arriver à n'importe quel
moment ouais j'aime beaucoup ce cavalier
F5 j'aime bien ce cavalier F5 parce que
ça ça ça propose leschange des des fous
donc ce fou c'est le bon fou des Noirs
quand on a un pion comme ça on veut de
pousser et en plus maintenant on a
réussi à même capturer ce pion quoi
prend des5 a faire une découverte faire
attention faut prend H3 car prend D5
c'est pas si évident non plus parce
quand même vis-à-vis qui peut arriver
style ça ça est-ce qu'on est prêt à
vraiment faire C4 et à obtenir un pion
un pion nous-même voilà c'est pas
vraiment peut-être c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'on ce qu'on recherche dans la
position donc peut-être
juste voilà ça ça attention au
petittit d'ailleurs sans doute à un
moment oui on va jouer à 5 tour1 et on
va manger le pion dans les bons dans les
bonnes conditions regardez le C6 jou
d'ailleurs C6 oui bon c'est logique hein
cavalier F5 qui peut arriver aussi
encore et là si vous regardez bien les
Blancs ont les deux cavaliers contre un
cavalier en G6 qui est bon il est ok
mais le fou C6 par contre c'est une très
mauvaise pièce donc l'idée c'est
vraiment d'obtenir cette position avec
le bon capalier contre le mauvais fou
sur le long terme joué t D1 maintenant
et on va pouvoir travailler la finale
avec une minute contre 30 secondes donc
la finale en des blanc bien sûr la
finale avec pion isolé c'est
clairementage blanc
ça plus F2 mettre F4 pour le cavalier
noir non je suis pas d'accord avec toi
vélo parce que F4 ça fait quandme pas
mal de casaz et et tu vois en plus après
F4 pourrais même moi installer un jour
un cavalier en E4 tu pourras plus me
chasser a ton pion tu vois
éventuellement souvent pour jouer contre
le cavalier G6 on peut comme G3 des fois
pour restreindre un petit peu ses ses
cases centrales mais F4 par contre c'est
un coup assez responsable généralement
quand tu es pas sûr de toi tu bouges pas
les pions comme ça F5 normal voilà
cavalier F5 normal et la tour cavalier
prend de son jouable mais carer prend
c'est logique à cause de tour4 peut-être
qui était jouable pour les Noirs tour4
ok pourch essayer d'échanger un maximum
la tour parce que la tour tape fracasse
le pion isolé et la Tour Noire va se
retrouver à la défense donc la finale de
pièce mineur il y a il y a des chances
de la tenir et du coup les blancs vont
garder la tour pour mettre la pression
ok G4 j'aime
bien parce que maintenant c'est vraiment
la la domination he et là ça va être
long long un se quart d'heur pour les
Noirs ouais il y a pas de cible regarde
elle change tout professionnel elle veut
bien elle veut bien maintenant là final
de la pièce mineure qui l'arrange et
c'est pas encore c'est pas encore
H5 AE AE aïe F4 G5 là ça ça donne envie
pr prise même prise prise c'est très
bien aussi avec F4 G3 oh ouais bloqué H4
s'est laissé bloquer sur case blanche
attention oui CIT c'était bizarre de pas
jouer F4 et G3 mais attention ils n'ont
plus de temps hein on le rappelle que
c'est facile d'être au commentaire et
plus difficile de jouer
elle a fait une bêtise auifan mais elle
est quand même mieux ah oui est quand
même très bien il y a un gros problème
quand même sur le sur la position là sur
le pion des5 est-ce qu'on va réussir à
le garder il y a il y a cavalier B4 et
F4 c'est Z
B4 il y avait encore ro B5 avec l'idée
d'aller attaquer le pion à 5 voilà B4
mais est-ce que mettre le cavalier en F4
ça peut être un peu la même idée
cavalier là et roi là
peut-être voilà c'est galère de jouer
cette position avec les Noirs c'est
perdu il faut que tu bouges il faut que
tu bouges une D4 prend 6 peut-être
gagne oua
malheureusement voilà P ah c'est facile
maintenant écoute partie très
convaincante he je pense de
an très conv pe certains auront vu que
le la la jauge dans la finale mais elle
évoluait beaucoup parce qu'il y avait
des gains manqués ou des coups de
défense manqué mais à cette cadence là
c'est normal super partie deouifan
technique très technique dans cette
première partie alors que c'est une
cadence hyper rapide céit agréable à
voir ouais ouais non mais IFAN
techniquement on l'a vu encore un match
contre costuk hein c'était quand même
c'était quand même plutôt bien ouais
ouais bien sûr S c'est plutôt
tactiquement qu'elle avait un petit peu
pêché par moment c'est ça c'est ça mais
elle cherchait les positions vraiment
stables oui ou oui là c'est Masterc
technique franchement c'est hyper
agréable qu'on a vu alors salut passion
échec sur Youtube alors saluez aussi les
gens qui nous regardent sur Youtube vous
savez que seulement 30 % ça je dis à
chaque fois seulement 30 % des de nos
viewers sur Youtube sont abonnés à la
chaîne alors je vous invite à vite vous
abonner à la chaîne Youtube c'est
gratuit et ça vous permet de rester
connecté et informé à chaque fois qu'on
fait quelque chose de nouveau il se
passe quoi sur PR5 ab5 c'est très
intéressant et tout ça là je regardais
mais j'osais pas tu vois j'ai même pas
proposé encore ça pouvait là c'est hyper
intéressant un sacrifice de pièce
positionnelle c'est chaud est-ce que ça
va être
jouer qu'elle va prendre la pièce
qu'elle pourrait simplement juste manger
là peut-être faut trouver un
coup B5 qui va être en l'air à un moment
ouais B5 un jour mais par contre areka
elle a obtenu ce qu'elle voulait
ouais une position un peu chaude quo
compliqué et ouifan doit déjà être en
train de regarder pour calmer un petit
peu le jeu et sortir vivante de ses
complications ouais
ouis les blancs on aime bien Yume ça ça
logique puis on est vraiment proche de
de développer toutes nos pièces
maintenant il faut trouver peut-être F 5
logique quand même avec l'idée de de
reprendre de la dame
stou
alors j'ai pas envie de manger ici parce
STR ser pas des
compensation je
[Musique]
prendstion aussi qui j'arve j'arrive à
l'URE
peutêre jouer ah j'ai aussi intermédire
effectivement voilà euh
ouais ça a l'air d'aller mais c'est vrai
que cette dame là qui est sorti c'est un
petit peu mieux pr est-ce que je peux
jouer autre chose que ça avec les blanc
et ok G4
waou in elle laisse pas bluffer là je
peux peut-être faire B4 sououf ah B4
c'est K3 F3 et pris C5 peut-être HM ok
alors on va voir un peu ce que tu
proposes P4 pour défendre le pion
cavalier prend je pe tout tenir et tu
manges de quoi du cavalier ouais c'est
ça l'idée c'est quand tu manges ici le
pion défend mais en plus attaque là donc
si tu manges mon cavalier je pourrais
manger le tien parce que le pion pourra
plus mais il y a encore ab5 dans cette
position il y a encore ça mais j'ai d C3
ouis je voulais faire ab5 au coup
d'avant ah d'accord ouais pour pas mais
ab5 a B4 il y a euub4 là on n pas du
tout ah si si il y a B4 blanc cavaler pr
alors peut-être qu'on va on va tomber
dans ta dans ta ligne ou mais5 a b5ouff
et j'arrive pas à trouver ce qu'on fait
sur a prend B5
euh si je prends là tu F prendin F prend
et ça pose des gros problèmes donc prend
C5 n'est pas jouable finalement il a eu
fou prend C5 c'est la partie ok du coup
là il y a pression sur E3 c'est ce qui
est très différent sur a prend B5 F
prend E3 les Noirs s'en sortent bien
ouais ça en l'air aussi à chaque fois
bien joué faut prendre C5 encore
avec ce cavalier G4 alors peut-être
douteux mais à la cadence où elle joue
c'est déjà une partie très animée au
bout de 10 coups h c'est super alors y
qui propose pour P 5 alors c'est vrai
qu'on a on a un petit délai de 20
secondes sur le stream ça c'est le
protocole antitriche euh qui a mis en
place chesscom fr enfin chesscom donc
quand vous postez un message sachez que
nous on le voit 20 secondes après oui
c'est pour ça qu'on Pr
réagir directement et salut Robin
sideide alors tu sais quoi euh
Kevin j'ai eu une plainte tu sais qu'ier
euh Robin side Robin side hier il a il a
supprimé un message ouais je sais je
sais un message de de Arnaud qui disait
au revoir à Hume quoi et euh et il a été
il a été
euh je sais pas si Arnaud est là mais il
s'est fait un petit peu corriger c'est
vrai qu'on dit pas on dit pas au revoir
àum quoi ça se fait pas et euh et Arnaud
écrit en privé après il m'a demandé mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait il a v le
message il a vu qu'il fait
fait bon c'est ça qu'on aime je lui ai
dit il a M C et Sam m'a dit mais j'ai
rien fait je suis même pas venu sur le
stream ah c'est génial et donc en fait
voilà je pense que on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé hier il s passé des choses
mais mais on sa pas encore vraiment mais
AR je sais pas s'il est là je crois
qu'il est je crois qu'il a il a bloqué
Robin toute
façon et là c'est le méga bordel qui
arrive parce que là vous voyez les
filles se rendent coup pour coup et la
la structure est hyper
étonnante avec une majorité ledame pour
les blancs mais paire de fou pour les
noirs et le roi E1 hyper bizarre préfère
jouer en en
partie rapide avec les noirs avec ce roi
E1 qui est ultra bizarre ouais d' pr C3
moi je largement les blancs ici je
trouve que c'est plus facile à jouer
mais attention un cavalier C4 qui est
bien jou
qui coup de toute façon ouais et là fou
F4 F4 est-ce que je peux jouer G3 G3 F
prend G3 ce serait du
délire cavalier D4 qui proposé par vé je
pense que c'est pas dans cette position
c'était avant4 c'est un coup
extraordinaire avec F3 et et cavalier D6
deux menaces et peut-être une variante
fou F4 G3 fou prend G3 h prend G3
dame pr G3 ro E2 on peut peut-être
regarder ça s parce que ça a l'air hyper
intéressant et je sais pas comment
évaluer ça c'est vraiment dur dur si
j'ai CAV D6 ça plus bien se passer quand
même hein même ouais c'est pour ça que
je pensis jouer peut-être petit rock ici
si j'ai le temps dame D3 ah ouais c'est
ça mon roi il arrive pas se je pense que
j'ai le temps de de de
Me bon on voit la jauge de toute façon
mais humainement avir le roi E2 c'est
toujours ultra bizarre ouais
ou mais une pièce en plus le roi 2 qui
tient le roi noir pas si ouis je pense
tuas pas assez de pièces pour même tour
G4 doit
suffire truc làhaut c'est moi qui vais
attaquer en fait elle a joué le fou B6
plus
sage je pense que vaêre
forc réussi à trouver la seule petite
magouille entre met de la position pour
contrer la paire de fou et ce fou3 c'est
super bien joué ouais etan elle a une
position Comand elle aime pas trop tout
à l'heure c'était très stable alors que
là depuis le départ c'est très créatif
alors elle est très forte aussi dans ce
registre là fan ou maisik on a vu hier
elle a du répondant dans ce style de
position oui elle est tactiquement elle
est quand même elle est quand même là on
l'a vu hier mais attention attention not
quand même chean là qui commence moins
bien
[Musique]
autant attention à ça faut commencer à
à à faire des coups là
ou B7 a été joué est-ce que j'ai pas de
temps prend B6
c'est qu'est-ce que tu proposes tout
pardon non non non non non j'aiosé une
bêtise petite
blague j'ai proposé une bêtise
euh non mais par contre d pr d' pr C7 et
prise en ass6 me plaisait bien oui ça
avait l'air très très bien un petit fou
qui attaqué là-haut
[Musique]
euh ilpr c'est bien aussi tour D1
CAV B5 tu gardes la pression
hein sur dame prend là il y a cavalier
prend échec il aa le fou B7 hein avec
fourchette faut trouver un coup là faut
trouver un coup j'ai du mal à trouver un
coup et voilà bah
IFAN aussi k prend B6 su fou B5 ça va
après dame prend ouais il y a plus de
coup is là je suis forcé de sur cavalier
prend j'ai pas le choix d il y avait dam
il y avait dam prend dam toutf en fait
il y avait plus de coup sur C prend B6
ah oui c'est vrai oui oui ouais sur dame
pr il y av déjà gagné peut-être
ouh attention C de la jauge qui descend
tout en bas et pourquoi ici fou prang
j'ai2 il y avait juste F2 ou elle a raté
juste ro F2 en fait et c'est fait euh
ok bon mais non ben écoute c'est pion de
plus pour les noirs et euh avec plus de
temps quand même pour
uneè de plus et temps elle pas réussi à
freiner juste un instant pour vérifier
ouais et la V va coûter cher sans doute
la partie on va voir si avec les 10
secondes quand même pouran est-ce
qu'elle va convertir ouais mais c'est
quand Mme ass
technique peut tenter peut-être de de
tirer une un match nul de cette position
pr D6 donc F pr forc
[Musique]
c6z ah il baisse ouais baisse in
contente allez
peutê en D2 hein attention il a ro E3
les deux pièces seront en
prises elle un peu imprécise là
c'est pas facile avec la cadence si raka
tire la nul c'est un moindre mal dans
cette partie oui oui encore gagner avec
le temps a commencé avec 2-0 euh c'est
pas pas facile bah surtout qu'elle doit
sentir qu'elle s'est fait un peu rouler
là ouais oh le pion G5 est-ce qu'il est
comestible il peutêtre F5 marrant qui
enfermé la tour je sais pas si c'était
possible bienû je pense que c'était
l'idée stouf ouais c'est très joli a gr
F6 à6 derrière surour B B6 on peut se
faire avoir là j'ai B7 et là x 6 B7
peut-être oh là là x 6 B7 j'ai l'IM trou
que cétait décisif ouais
elle a pas
assuré mant les noir vont gagner avec 8
plus de coup elle avait 40 secondes elle
pou s l'adversaire peut-êre raté arrive
pas à faire les bons stop tour C7 oh là
encore un revirement Stouff oh les revir
c'est dur ave le manque de temps plus
temp estce que tu peux manger
il j'avais envie de
miltr je pense si jamais j'arrive à
changer- que je vais réussir comment on
fait coup maintenant
j'ai encore G4 G5 je pense ah ouais H5
H4 ça va ça fait nul
mais pas
évidentroable est- que je pas sur
H et c'est nul mais il faut si conna
c'est
nulition je pense que oui estce que tu
connaisition
incroable Chan voyez que le temps malgré
une énorme bêtise d'Arik c'est la
partie vous voyez maintenant que
l'aspect temps a une grande importance
queifan elle aurait converti tous les
jours cette position ouais sauf que bah
évidemment en crise de temps il peut
tout se passer vous avez le thème
d'opposition et
nul allez 1 et demi dans ce match an
qui qui s' sort bien ouais ouais parce
que c'était elle qui était vraiment mal
au départ et on a le droit à une
Française plutôt
une Française ça
italienne en même temps on a vu que
l'italienne s'était mal
passé alors cavalier F6
hier quoi comme français hier c'est
bien des Françaises comment
ou CTA avec cost les win avec dam 5
alors attends c'était quoi qu'est-ce
qu'on a vu comme française c'était une
Française d'avance F 2 je crois si je
dis pas de bêtises ok bon cette ligne
est ass connu 4 qui existe déjà ouis et
je crois que 4 c'est quasiment forcé non
oui oui dans ce genre de position on a
joué pour
cela 5 C3 on prend D4 et sont très
intéressantes structur
parlant et wi fan qui se tient la
tête oui B pourtant à une époque elle
devait connaître cela par cœur
ouais on voit qu'elle a un petit peu
rouillé théoriquement parlant puisque
elle a pris beaucoup de temps alors
qu'elle a déjà joué ce type de position
c'est certain ouais mais c'est toujours
un petit peu cassegueule Stouff hein
c'est ce début-là salut
AR il est
là
cend il
diff passé
hier queil
[Musique]
passé
OK bon ça va pas être mauvais non plus
hein j'imagine mais c'est pas euh c'est
pas euh on va dire principal hein je
crois peut-être elle veut juste la
petite finale donc échanger les fot cas
noir mettre une dame en D4 jouer B4 et
puis échanger et travailler cette
position elle aimerait bien une partie
dans la même veine ouais voilà on le
voit arriver hein tu prend les qu voilà
l'idée c'est vraiment de d'échanger les
pièces et garder le contrôle de la case
des4 c'est important pour enfermer le
fou c'est vite que le fou pu pas r
sortir si les noir on dur P généralement
ils vont ils vont essayer de prendre le
pour D4 pour ouvrir ce ou ce fou un
genre
F6 le coup thématique de la française
aussi peut être voilà bah tiens hop on a
on y a le
droit parce qu'il faut faire quelque
chose sinon c'est une Mor lente un petit
peu dans le même style que tout à
l'heure et là on joue plutôt avec pr F6
non ou plutôt avec B6 j'ai je vais pas
avir
des masses de
choix parce que bah j'ai ça et ça j'ai
deux choix je pense oui et j'ai Laim
pression sur5 qui fait que je vais
devoir prendre une décision quoi qu'il
en soit c'est ça là l' cavalier prend d'
prend cavalier prend et éventuellement
une prise dans le 5 même si j'ai quand
même cavaler prendre le 6 mais bon ça pu
tour 8 ou ah non tour 8 mais bon tu as
pas envie de calculer tout ça tu es
moins bien autant tuas 2 minutes de Mos
a laissé la structure elle préféit
attendre donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
maintenant sur prise 5 et le retour du
cavalier en D7
euh y a cavalier CME cavalier C7 qui qui
peut arriver on aurait encore un pion
isolé il y a eu A5 ro D2 al la position
là c'est une finale hein donc c'est
normal de ne pas roquer je je pense que
ça serait une erreur de faire petit rock
bien sûr c'est pas non plus une grosse
erreur mais mais ça
là j'ai envie de rentrer
fe5 et tour F2 et tour F2 alors sur fe5
est-ce que je suis obligé de manger je
dirais que oui moi j'ai pas vu d'autres
alternativ mais j'ai aussi pris 5
intermédiaire peut-être qui peut te
mettre à tour en ah je sais pas ok c'est
pas grave enfin voilà ça ferait partie
de F des7 elle a pas osé prendre hein
ouais il F D7 donc là on peut imaginer
cavalier
des4 c'est une bonne ce pour le cavalier
en
D6 souvent et là on pense qu'on a un
beau cavalier en D6 mais des fois ce
cavalier fait pas grandchose alors là en
D6 c'est vrai que une des choses que je
fais c'est que j'empêche cavalier C4
intéressant mais d'un autre côté c'est
qu' en D4 j'attaque le petit pion qui
est faible en E6 j'ai peur de j'ai
toujours peur aussi Souf de prise 5 et
tour F2 he je reviens à la charge avec
cette thématique là ouais qui est
tellement logique pour ça activé avec la
noire roi3 été joué tu vois bah
d'ailleurs elle en avait peur je sais
pas si elle a pas raté roi2 quand les
pris5 et du coup méf hein peut-re
peut-être mais là du coup les les Noirs
ont réussi à échanger le leur mauvais
fous oui puis est inquiétant he et ouais
prise et tour C8 peut-être tour C8 de
suite ouais t ouais tour a C8 je pense
Mme manger aussi d'abord manger T8 ah
ouais c'est bien elle va fracasser tous
les pions Harik elle a perdu le contrôle
elle éta en train de bien contrôler la
position et sur la séquence ro D2 roi E3
il est clair queifan a perdu le contrôle
et maintenant elle va jouer presque pour
faire nul hein ouais dans un premier
temps on verra après suretour prend ro
là t bouge j'ai tout attaqué le pion là
j'ai roi C5 un roi C5 à la Stouff voilà
j'étais sûr que tu vois comme quoi j'ai
senti déjà cette partie était plutôt
raisonnable et sou nous amène du
déraisonnable à gro C5 qui est peut-être
très intéressant Cendant bah c'est actif
hein il faut jouer
actif et ouais le roi monte mais bon
tour 1
aussi très normal le CAV est mal placé
en en B6 hein mais en tout cas là il
faut j'avoue aussi qu'av qu'était
possible qui empêcher ro C5 ouais ouais
ouais ouais ben on essaie de stabiliser
et fou B5 il y avait tour E4 donc
c'était totalement
jouable bon tour G5 cependant n'est pas
une grosse erreur he là je pense que la
jauge ça exagère parce que c'est quand
même un des coups candidat
là on donne G2 pour manger aussi je
pense c'est une bonne opération blan F7
peut-être avec l'idée ro7 parce que
notre roi est loin du du jeu ramen ro
RAM ro c'est très bien coup j
bien pas
oui ok
moi
pourêcher oubl pour les tactiques on av
dit qu'elle était pas en forme
tactiquement dans dans son premier match
même si l'avait gagné bah là forc
constater que elle a vu la petite
tactique je navais pas vu et Harik non
plus et Harik elle est toujours bien au
temp par contre ouais elle joue vite
elle met la pression mais exact pour
l'inant ça se passe pas trop trop bien
pour pour elle dans ce match parce qu'au
final elle rate ça et après tu prends le
6 il y a un peu tout en prise quoi et le
roi qui est maintenant sorti et qui va
être en danger en terme de stratégie
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'elle fait Harik
malheureusement elle a quelques Mons de
flottement alors qu'elle a du temps et
qu'elle a mis la la ouifan sous pression
il faut dire que ouifan sous pression
elle joue très bien aujourd'hui hein
ouais elle joue mieux j'ai l'impression
que contre Alexandra costenou où elle
avait beaucoup souffert ouifan dans le
3+ 1 et le 5+ 1 pour se refaire en
buulette mais là elle rigole pas
franchement elle fait quand même des
grosses parties avec beaucoup d'envie de
contrôle
oui tactiquement elle est propre elle
est propre alors que contre ctinu qui
avit qu même dé Gâts c'est ça
stratégiquement était là et tactiquement
comme tu le dis était un peu en retrait
de ce qu'elle fait de ce qu'elle produit
d'habitude ouais bon après là on est
qu'au début du match pour l'instant
benah on est très content de de de de de
voir ce qu'elle fait elle produit de des
beauéchec et après F F5 qu'est-ce qu'on
fait maintenant là là c'est problème
hein caler C4 mais du coup là j'ai au
moins deux pions deux pions en
prise au moins ça si ce
n'est même foupran aus c'est un coup
jouable même fouprend avec tour F7 avec
le foupr5p de men c'est que faut prend 6
peut-être roi des 6 tu me diras c'est la
partie apparemment c'était pas le
meilleur ça donn envie mais roi des6
allez on le joue
voilà encore prend là peut-être oui et
son retour prend je prends ici bon bah
avec aend B4 j'arriverai peut-être à un
truc comme
çaà et du voilà tour C8 peut-être
d'abord d'ailleurs et tour D2 quelque
chose comme ça donc bon il y a il y a
encore
vent la pression du temps est récompensé
ai sa stratégie du départ mais lu manque
pas grandchose on sent
pour de manière constante et à du temps
et malheureusement pour elle là c'est
compliqué
maintenant grand crise temps tout à
l'URE çat du n'importe quoi quand éta
vraiment très mal temp qui logique on
peut plus tout contrôler il y a une
minute d'avance pour position qui lui a
glissé entre les
mains j'ai juste
peuttreour surour ici
veut ça joue encore avec tour par
exemple sal sur Youtube
sal salut
cécileend D5
ou ça va ég cette position ouais on a
chacun elle regarde quoi elle regarde
tour G4 éch qui est un peu plus
bizarre4 tour 4
ouais bon
tour ça pas mal5
derrière ok c'est compliqué de jouer B5
pour B5 pourquoi B5 c'est la même
position sauf que j'ai ouais mais j'ai
un P de plus non ah tu veux me mat waouh
ouais elle s'est trompé hein parce que
roi C3 oublié sans doute ouais et
maintenant donc tour C1 et tour ici
alors il a peut-être pour prend C de
faire attention mais genre sur ça ça
peut-être tour F7 là il faut là il faut
le tranquille avec les Blancs ouais avec
6 secondes on va voir mais elle a de
bonnes chances de gagner cette fois-ci
euh oui passer ici il faut calmer un peu
le jeu cette tour ici est bien ouais
pour aller manger le pion qui est
indéfendable he sur B5 j'ai tour a 5
tour pr 4 on en voit le pion h le plus
loin possible mais c'est trop un pion
hein ouais là j'ai quand même tris pion
passés TR B3 aussi tranquillement tour
C5 bien joué on peut envoyer le pion a
nous aussi ti regarde maintenant la tour
qui pas et tour i le tour c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle voilà c'est fini
maintenant on va on va pousser
tranquille c'est facile même avec le peu
de temps c'est
perdu incroyable encore
an qui gagne cette partie était pas
était pas favorite encore dans cette
partie non non
nonik ça va lui faire du mal quand même
au casque on pourrait voir
attention plus
2 plus 2 ça joue très vite ça peut être
après la fidélisation ouais 2 et demi il
reste encore 53 minutes en 5+ 1
alle c'est reparti pour la lapine
l' cavalier à
[Musique]
3 bon cétait plutôt convainquant tout à
l'heure ce qu'on essayé les
blancs pas mal ce qu'elle a fait j'ai
bien aimé répète répète
encore on a vu quoi on a vu4
ou on a vu G4 rej reje
é fait on a vu
cavalier et F prend
C5 peut-être qu'elle connaissait jusque
là et4 ça ça a surpris et du
coup refait son
B4 et ça rejoue prend C5 elles vont
checker peut-être à la pause cette
position il y a des grandes Chan
qu' même quelqu'un qui check pour
elle impossible
souvent les joueurs ont des
second leur permet de pouvoir checker je
crois que MV il faisait ça avec avec B
tout à l'heure c'était F3 la partie
euh cavalier C4 me semble-t-il oui mais
il y a pas eu là il y a eu
B5 F B6 dame D6 et donc là il y a eu B5
nouveau mais c'est pas mal parce que ça
met pression sur le C A5 donc le fou en
C5 ouais tu prends là à moitié
comestible et je blasse ça et si tu
prends là je prends là a
priori mais tu peux toujours faire la
même avec prise et cavalier C4 non ouais
mais là je peux prendre en un dame
prends un et tu as plus le motif en D6
HM Kevin il FLA pas ilabandonne
moi je suis pas comme ça
moi moi je te j'ai une bonne anecdote
récente donc au Cap d'AG j'ai fait le
tournoi de de Blitz et la première
partie je sais pas si je t'ai raconté ça
stouf pas je suis tombé au temps et j'ai
fait match nul parce que j'ai fait une
parpète ultra rapide c'està dire que
j'ai empêché mon adversaire de regarder
la pendule alors ça marche moyennement
si regarde la pendule hein cette
histoire j'ai fait perpè et et du coup
il a pas regardé la pendule il m'a dit
nul bah je lui dit ok donc je vouis le
grand maître sol vchenko qui est quand
même vraiment fort et c'était assez
marrant quand même qu'il ne regarde pas
la prendule pris par la
perpétuelle j'ai vu que j'étais tombé
j'ai vu que j'étais tombé dans ce cas-là
quoi c'était assez marrant bon pas ta é
ouais c'est ça non mais complètement
mais une fois que vous serrez la main
c'est terminé hein exactement score mais
estce que en fait l'arbitre aurait pu
aurait dû même
intervenir ça ça ça change tout le
tempsin il y a des moments où l'arbitre
doit intervenir plus que d'ut fois là il
pouvait P mais il l'a pas fait non et
bon après c'est blit imagine qu'il y a
beaucoup
table pas vraiment parce que là la phase
finale si tu veux donc il y avait
c'était par groupe donc il avit qu
tables de joueurs tu vois cé phase
finale et en plus c'était cétait pas en
même temps quoi c'était tu faisais jouer
la PO a après céit la p B c'est un super
tourno de blit à
[Musique]
faire bien jou c'est sévère pour harika
si oifan vient convertir son net
avantage d'un pion dans cette position
puis y a du temps pour les les deux
jeunes femme cette
fois c'est du coup dur dur
oui j'ai donc j'étais assez content Souf
de donc de mon fait d'armes d'avoir fait
nul alors que j'étais tombé au temp mais
la partie suivante j'ai j'ai au bout de
H coup j'étais foutu donc du coup
c'était c'éit moins grandiose quoi c'est
l'ascenseur émotionnel Blitz évidemment
ça va très très vite dans les dans les
deux sens ouais c'est la première fois
que ça m' arrivait de de ne pas perdre
en étant tombé autant c'est pas courant
je crois que ça m'est jamais
[Musique]
arrivé ça c'est quand spécial comme
comme comme condition mais
[Musique]
euh mais bon après tu me demande si tu
me demandes si j'ai déjà gagnéun dame de
moins je veux dire oui j'ai déjà gagné
avec deux tours de moins en partie
ouioui ah oui ça de c'est beaucoup j'ai
non mais en fait j'avais joué une fois
en N1 et euh et je safie une qualité h h
euh sur une pièce en D4 et je savais
qu'après euh je t reprendre des 4 fa t
reprend et j'ai fou C5 dame B6 en fait
je clouer cette pièce et finir par la
manger en fait et je pensais gag je
pensais gagner une pièce sauf que j'ai
oublié à un qui se décloue avec une
grosse grosse menace et en fait et ben
je perds une qualité et une
tour donc en fait j'avais pas de tour de
moi j'avais j'avais une tour et une
qualité de moi et bon ben je suisu
complet et puis là mon adversaire il il
avait quand même beaucoup moins V que
moi il avait à peu près 1900 2000 il
stressait pas mal je le voyais un peu
stressé ouais et puis arrive un moment
où on fait une séance un peu à tempo
tempo genre je joue il joue on note je
joue joue et je r un peu fou tu vois en
essayant de mettre la pression et euh et
puis arrive dans i quelques tempo tempo
où je suis mat en en trois etcheque
écheque mat et un autre coup qui me fait
mat imparable le problème c'est que moi
j'avais fait une menace toute discrète
en espérant qu'il me fasse la position
où je suis ma imparable ah oui c'est sur
le truc oùam H6 et un pion F6 c'est
mon Mo j'avais vu que si faisait un
comme ça et ben j'avais un ma avant
j'avais le fameux mat àétouffer avec
dame B6
cavalier et euh et l'autre mat échec
échec est un peu plus dur à voir et et
comme il stressait il tremblait et
cetera en plus il av du tempsendu il a
vu du temps donc mais comme ilessé il il
a fini par jouer cette ligne très vite
dansage 6 et quand j'ai B6 il s'est
décomposé non je comprends et moi j'ai
tout content
ouais bien sûr par équipe oui oui oui et
cétait par équipe mais en plus ouais je
me souviens que ce match là j'étais pas
très content parce changé la compo le
matin même parce qu'il y avait un de
équipe qui était venu de loin et qui
voulait
pas jouer parce qu' cont 1900 il vou
jouer un plus for du coup le matin m'a
tien tu vas jouer ça non dou les noirs
du coup si du coup ça coupétais
coupétais pas
cont je voilà voilà
voilà pour mais ça arrive c'est anecdote
j'ai la même en Top 16 contre François
Godard je me rappelle qui est un maître
belge il m'avait marché dessus durant
toute la partie on fait un énorme zot
quand même mais il me finit quoi on va
dire et au au 40e coup il se lève il se
lève totalement gagnant et il faute au
41e mais genre il peut faire échec échec
suivi d'un Matth qui va arriver ou faire
le mat imparable aussi sauf que j'avais
mat en 3 mois aussi tu vois histoire
analogue à la tienne Stouff quoi ça peut
arriver ah ouais ouais comme quoi
jusqu'à la fin il faut vraiment faut se
battre le dernier coup de raquette h
sinon c'était l'histoire de
robinide robinide il joue un grand
maître à 2600 lo lors d'un tournoi et
puis bon il est il est moins bien mais
il se bat il se bat il se bat et puis
bon ils arrivent au 40e coup et euh et
puis bah robinide B il se lève Bonon
j'aV l'incrément quoi qui va arriver
donc il se lève il va il va aux
toilettes il va se prendre va voir et
cetera et quand il revient laversaire
avait signé la feuille et ben robinide
avait perdu autant un tourno il y avit
pas d'incrément en 40e oui c'est ça
c'est PI et ça ça fait mal et oua
surtout quand es bien battu mais c'est
une anecdote qui arrive assez
fréquemment c'est Nicolas clé au capdag
parce Queau capdag c'est pareil il n'y a
pas de de rajoute temps en 40e ouais et
il s'est fait avoir comme ça aussi mais
sauf qu'il était vraiment dans une
position il pouvait plus perdre genre
pion de plus en finale qu'il va
convertir normalement moi j'ai une autre
anecdote comme ça la la même anecdote
euh une joueuse qui avait 200 ho qui
joue contre un grand maître euh un grand
maître espagnol qui a un style très
particulier c'est larinho je pas si tu
connais ouais qui avait à l'époque 2500
et quelques et c'était finale tour 3
pion contre tour ok ah oui et tour 3
pion ben je me lève par que bon ben
j'arrive au 40e j'ai un r de temps et et
tu perds autant alors que tu as 2100 tu
fais ta grosse peur tu B re
et ça ça c'est c'est
triste horrible mais bon c'estéchec
après c'est un peu ta faute il faut que
tu sois au
courant6 encore encore dame G3 je
c le coup
[Musique]
probablement
pe galère non
par en tout cas domination totale
d'ouifan mais qui n'a plus que 20
secondes donc on s'est un peu arrêté de
commenter ouais mais on va rentrer dans
le vif du sujet la conversion est bonne
pour l'instant côté noir depuis le
départ
et est-ce que maintenant les blancs vont
réussir le hold up
ouais il y a cavalier5 qui
s'annonce dame D4 aussi qui peut arriver
Caval 5 ça ouais là dame C5
on se déclou il y a toujours le problème
tour des6tit tour D6 voilà un
peuemporiser dame C4 peut être une idée
attention la tour quand même deuxème
pion n croquet il pas de problème
apparent ouis ro H7 peutre une bonne
idée avec cavalier5 sans perd la tour
sur échec là-haut voilà a été joué bien
jou stou et maintenant D4 ouais t D4
pour Esser de bouger le cavalier les
Clouets on a un petit dame C7 qui peut
qui peut à un moment être intéressant
pour enlever le cavalier exactement
cavalier là c'est abandon direct par
contre a a a mauvais coup làand et je
pense que la pause va arriver on va
Leser jouer qui qui nous quitte donc on
a 20 secondes de retard sur elle et ça
va quand même abandonner çaabandonne
parce que j'attaque la dame le fou et la
tour et Harik qui est pas bien réveillé
hein mais tu vois c'est un petit peu
grosse option pour
an c'est un peu tu vois aussi le
fait après le gros match ce qu'elle Ava
fait hier c'est pas évident tu vois de
de renchaîner le lendemain alors queifan
elle a quand même eu plusieurs journées
de repos parce que oui après je pense
aussi se trouve que ça aurait pu tourner
différemment super partie d'ifan à la
première et dans la deuxième elle met la
pression autant dans la trisième aussi
elle a pas réussi à convertir et même
bah elle a fait 0,5 sur 2 dans ses
rondes 2 et 3 où c'était jouable elle a
laissé passer un petit peu sa chance
pris un coup au moral et là ça devient
beaucoup plus dur elle est dans le dur
je sais pas si elle va réussir à revenir
ouais ça va dépendre d'ifan si IFAN joue
à son meilleur niveau on la reverra plus
ouais ouais TR points de retard déjà
c'est difficile et après plus laance
accélère on a vu hier que en bullette
elle a été très
forteifan un peu fébrile des fois en fin
de partie donc on peut toujours il peut
y avoir un comeback mais il faudrait que
qu'elle arrive un peu à limiter la carte
en tout cas en 5 + 1 et qu'elle revienne
après la pause dans de meilleurs
condition ouais tout à fait parce que là
c'est mentalement aussi que ça commence
à être dur quand on commence à à pas
gagner une partie 35 ça commence à être
cher je sais pas si tu as une pub à
lancerououi je va lancer la pub donc je
vous dis à tout de suite dans 5 minutes
à peu près on revient avec Kevin pour
voir la suite du match super à tout de
suite à tout de
suite
[Musique]
c'est
l' les jouus ça va bastonner maintenant
ouis 305 là
elle doit absolument faire l'effort d'
on est reparti sur une italienne avec
H6 H6 avec G5 plus tard donc pas de bien
sû j'aime beaucoup c'est une des
variante que j'aime conseiller aux
élèves de mémoire j'ai même fait une
vidéo à mes débuts sur YouTube sur ce
sujetl et c'est une des bonnes
alternative par rapport à l'italienne
classique h
oui d'ailleurs hier on a vu une
italienne à un moment avec F 7 à 4 tu
sais petite FO 7 on pr l'espace avec
A4 il a A4 aussi mais c'est très
différent
allez le tout pour le tout ouais G5
ici j'ai vu car de mémoire qu'il a joué
il y a pas longtemps avec les Blancs je
sais qui beaucoup de joueurs aiment
jouer h G5 H6 G6 aussi chez les Français
c'est Axel deor qui aime bien6 aussi ou
qu' l'a joué en tout cas on peut jouer
les
deux un jour on
envisage de naviguer sur l' ro
évidemment tout pousser on pas oigé
direct ouais tu peux même rocker même
petit ro est possible ici tout à fait on
pe faire petit Ro et après continuer à
travailler avec cavalier7 G6 G4 et plein
d'autes possibilités un cavalier H5
cavalier F4
G4 il y a plein plein d'idées mais CTA
intéressant et agressif ça peut sortir
en tout cas
an de ses de confort ouais la secouet
pour éviter une partie bah trop dans son
style on a vu que positionnellement
quand elle commence à contrôler la
position particulièrement dans la
première partie c'était très beau très
propre et franchement la première partie
était hyper impressionnante et pourrait
servir pour nos cours respectifs hein
stouf avec la Masterc contre le pion
isolé les échanges de pièces elle
cumulait beaucoup de de choses c'est
bien ce petit fou G4 j' bien fou G4 sur
k G3 si tu voulais faire ça et ben
j'avais k D4 bien sûr là je
cro H5 le cavalier en F4 hein
bizarre
ça bon la contrepartie c'est qu'à un
moment je peux jouer du dame B3 et du D4
alors dame B3 faut vérifier que j'ai le
droit de le jouer directement pour taper
F7 et B7 c'est peut-être ça qu'elle a vu
ou fan pour ce goinfis des cases
blanches
ouais est-ce que c'est
[Musique]
ouais tu peux
manger ouais après tu me fais peur quand
même parce que bien sûr pour arriver en
H3 mais j'ai mme3 donc je croque allez
je croque j'y vais dans cette position
sur ça tu manges ici peut-être ouais j
vais et sur ça B5 voilà
ouais
ouais ça a l'air comestible quand même
ça l'air OK he là la je qui aime pas
trop ce qu'on fait mais j'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi non c'est pas 7 je
reviens ici ouais je repar tour B8 pour
fixer ma dame et après tu fais comment
je men c'est pas ça la Jae apparemment
ime pas
cel non on aaime pas ça non plus moi je
non mais il doit y avoir quelque chose
ah peut-être G4 stouf ah non j'arrive
pas à le
jouer je je vais mettre l'ordi 2
secondes ouais B là c'est pas facile de
voir petit rock ah en fait oui ilsétait
pas très ils sont dame B3 juste ou je
voulais jouer dame B3 je pensais que ça
allait ah il met ton cavalier en en E7
F4 ah oui d'accord c'était quand même
long long termist c'était pas facile
pour non clairement clairement pas clair
ou oui et il y a eu qui avait G3 qui
avait 7 et dame B3 maintenant ouais donc
tu vois on nétait pas si loin de une
certaine vérité dans le sens ouais c'est
quand même pas pas facile à maintenant
j'aurais directement t B8 si tu manges
en B7 hein et tu risques de perdre un
petit pion ici ah R est récompensé de
son choix d'ouverture plus ambitieux
ouais après c'est pas encore fait par
contre parce que c'est très déséquilibré
il y a la per de fou on échange d'une
position de roi
affaibli et puis
tire aussi he que dès que je cavalier G6
c'est cavalier F5 qui va arriver aussi
donc il un peu les deux côtés
hein al D4 a été joué logique onou la
position fou 3 t D1 va arriver
probablement
derrière d'ailleurs on n pas fait le la
prédiction prédiction ah je connais
quand ouais j'ai euh j'ai j'ai oublié
mais bon de toute façon là je pense que
si on fait une trition maintenant je vis
pas non plus rappeler euh
ouais mais je pense que ça va pas bien
se passer si si on fait la prédiction de
suite hein 3 et5 0 et5i qui va qui va
parier sur euh
ik tu as vu euh stouf depuis qu'on on
parait plus je t'ai je t'ai raconté hier
que l'agno allait écraser harika et là
euh aujourd'hui je s dit harika peut
peut-être inquiéter son adversaire et
dans les deux cas ça ne se vérifie pas
attention en fait je crois que je crois
que tu es pas très bon en prédiction
Kevin ouais ouais ouais mais quand Paris
plus je fa pas trop attention
sououf je suis un peu léger dans les
paris tu souviens dans tous mes Paris
moi à chaque fois je paris sur Prague et
ben je crois que maintenant tu vois à
force de parier sur lui j'ai réussi
à
maintenant je parie sur l'avenir jeou
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça tout à
fait quand au capdag à la 8e ronde je me
suis pris sa prépa contre un joueur à
2002 ouais tu men as parlé horrible
c'était horrible quand j'ai vu euh ça
sur la
fin quel
dommage cavalier 5 cavalier prend le 5
cavalier prend F3 qui est une menace et
même G4 que mon Saci être une menace
hein un jour parce qu'avec je prends F3
ça me lasse des choses sur F pr j'ai
cavalier prend attaque à je 2 j'ai
l'impression que il y a trop trop de
menac comment je défends je fou
de c'est Caval 5 F4 c'est un peu lent
j'ai toujours fou
pr de juste
che mais je suis pas sûr j parce qu'en
fait il y a souvent prise et fou F4 qui
peut défendre quand
même pas sû que ce soit le coup fou
c'est la
partie c pr F3 bien sûr
parti mais je me demande si j' pas
peut-être plus fort que qu'a F3 un coup
qui pouvait
euh tout cas ça fait peur m cavalier
prend 4 encore une fois je prends tous
les pions
hein prend 4 prend attention hein
attention que il y a a des tactiques un
peu dans tous les
sens ça a l'air de marcher
hein peut-être que je peux pas
manger peut-être que je ne peux pas
manger attends j'en l'ORD j' pas vu je
l'avais bon en tout cas là c'est quand
même position très difficile pour pour
les blancs ouais c'est difficile hein
IFAN devrait jouer sans doute un peu
plus vite
ouais cavalier F4 n pas possible à quel
moment AR
euh cavalier F4 je vois pas à quel
moment tu me demande on va essayer de
bétonner fan elle a des petites chances
de tenir cette position en G6 excuse-moi
rapidement bien sûr bien sûr C
intéressant prend F4 tout le temps en
fait AR et bon par contre cavalier F4 ça
ça va l'air rigolo de ramener un
deuxième cavalier tu vois stouf ouais
cavalier France c'est c'est c'est c'est
un peu l j'ai
l'impression oui mais attends il y a pas
des F qui arrivent bon aès c'est pas
grave mais il y avait peut-être F PR5
pour le pion H2 mais bon ok ok bon
peut-être y a des choses mais là on
vaêre c'est plutôt direct mais c'est
vrai que
euh Caval F4 si je peux le mettre c'est
vraiment génial mais si a fou prend et
qu'après je mets du temps à ramener
encore les autres pièces à l'attaque ça
peut être long et ici euh
il F4 et les blancs sont pas bien les
blancs juste jouent pour pour ne pas
mourir hein donc bon en qu'à faire si je
peux repousser un peu l'attaque je suis
content et là il y a une proposition de
NLE implicite
refusé par areka oui oui mais elle est
en train de de s'activer auifan ouais
mais c'est pas encore fini hein je c de
5 qui peut revenir tembête un petit peu
ah bah de toute façon comme il y a un
gros pion de plus pour les Noirs mais on
sent que les Blancs ont réussi à faire
quelque chose peut-être F4 pour pour
justement sortir le le fou C1 et jouer
dynamique je pense qu'il faut le faire
on a un pion moins on peut prendre des
risques on n pas
peur on est dopé par le fait d'être
moins bien cavalier prend G7 jouer CELI
de F4 bon F4 direct c'était peut-être la
même chose ouais le cavalier é quand
même pas mal en F5 peut-être qu' aurait
pu faire des choses notamment sur le P
H6 complètement donc F4 cétait bien je
pense le coup parce que elle a eu l'idée
he mais bon elle a pas beaucoup de temps
he vous savez les deux jeunes femmes là
maintenant sont sous la pression sous la
minute c'est c'est plus pareil c'est
plus les mêmes échecs et avantage Harik
ça lui ferait du bien ça relancera un
peu le match et le suspense
risque d'assister un match sens unique
tour peuttre
maintenant
C4 jeis le faire tour C5 on
pr magnifique
OK mais ok maintenant c'est je manger
manger là et à la fin j'ai quand même la
tour qui vient en deuxème en style ça ça
ça ça alors j'ai peut-être ça déjà de
base tour C8 ah non il y a atttion ah a
échec et juste tour tour en bas ouais
mais B4 et tour C7 franchement je suis
pas serein
avec c'est vrai c'est pas clair ou c'est
pas clair du tout c'est fait c'est la
partie ah avoir il y a pas eu comme ça
elle a juste joué celle-là il y a eu il
y a pas eu Caval pr 4 il y a eu tour
prend4 c'est pas mal tour prend4 c'est
un peu mieux mais après fou fou5 ah fou
E5 je peux manger hein tu as pas de tour
C6 tu as pas de moyen d'attaquer mon
cavalier pour l'instant ouais tout à
fait donc TR la tour là
échec comment je sors de le peut-être
juste tour mais avec 6 secondes c'est
chaud pour les deux joueuse tour 1 tour
E6 j'arrive à à m'en sortir hein je vais
jouer pour peut-être tour D7 à un moment
ouais prise pris t D7 pas le temps ouais
tour5 tour 6 tour marche pas mieux là je
je vais essayer de répéter en attendant
tour
B6 allez j'essaie de liquider si les
blancs arrivent à liquider tous les dam
c'est
OK alle les Noirs comment ça il y a plus
de temps à la penduin c'est très
chaud est-ce qu'on envoie le roi ah
j'aurais joué roi E4 j'aurais joué pour
l'activité
plutôt que subir on monte le roi subit
trop subit trop elle aurait dû là
victoire sans doute d'Arik prochaine
qu'on joue H3 pour tenter c'est perdu he
m C3 derrière je crois que c'est ça je
vais tenter t B4 ça fait trop attention
au roi quand même hein pas trop le roi
noir peut aussi tenter d'aller chercher
le pion à 5 à un moment ouais c'est ce
qui va se passer probablement ça va être
dur avec une seconde de tenir ça ouais
tour B5 voilà tour B7 c'était beaucoup
mieux elle a oublié mais elle avait plus
de temps avec H3 qui va arriver et le
roi qui va partir par là-bas je
pense maintenant que tout est défendu on
ramène le
roi t B5 son adversaire là çare un
Bandon deux pions
passés voilà ben écoute
fait bien c'est ça premier point pour
pourka ça fait ça fait du bien en moral
on a failli revenir en plus qu'elle est
partie de très très loin quand même
ouais
finalement c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
Harik certes mais elle montre quand même
plus de fragilité elle est passé à côté
de son ouverture elle a quand même
failli
l'emporter c'est un coup que je ne
connais
[Musique]
pas
curieux et réfléchit en regardant son
clavier
ouis là de Ben B4
oui avec H6 qui est pas toujourser G6
peut-être
oua voulait jouer H5 commeanglaise dans
position là mais je crois pas non ou ou
pas l'air très s non elle a pas l'air
contente
euh toujours frustrant donc cavaler C6
par contre c'est bizarre sa B5 souvent
c'est des bonnes réaction dans le Benco
quand tu met cavalier ici exactement
stouf B53 peut-être parce que là
vraiment les noirs sont en retard avec
ce petit cou6 j'ai envie d'exploser le
centre B5 E3 on fait mal
oui ça çav d'ailleurs souvent tu peux le
ça Yume qui a leou dans sa vie euh il y
a des il y a plein de setup quand tu
joues avec avec reti avec les Blancs
quand prenne le centre avec D4 avec D5
C54 D4 B4 c'est une grand grande
option belle option avec ah oui fait VI
de rater deux ouvertures consécutives
ouais D3 c'est dommage 3 il y a pas le
risque de se prendre plôt 3 Mo oh là là
dommage ouais elle a voulu comme elle
sent qu'elle est mieux elle a voulu un
peu assurer mais dommage tuas pas
forcément besoin je pense3 tu vas manger
ça peut marcher je sais pas la seule
raison de pas jouer3 direct c'est
d'avoir peur de D3 ouais mais d c'est
pas pas c'est pas pas ici quoi pr pr
elle est quand même très bien malgré
tout ah oui elle a un avance avec b5ance
avec6
donc avec les Blancs et de en avance en
plus B il y a déjà un problème hein s je
sais pas quoi jouer ici je prends de E
et je joue fou E7 mais il y aura tour1
dame2 ouais ça c'est extrêmement dur
parce que je peux plus bouger je peux
Pasquer parce que je perds le fou donc
cavalier F8 là c fou E6 ou cavalier E6
ouais bah c'est ça on parti mais dame 2
est très bien ouais cavalier F8 pour
mettre une pièce devant cavalier 5 al l'
très fort il y a des histoires sur la
colonne sur la diagonale il y a ouf ok
c'est ce qu'elle ce qu'elle a joué mais
l'ordinateurétait en plus plus le coup
attendu qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fallu
jouer pour vraiment profiter l'avantage
ah peut-être cavalier H4 ave l'idée
cavalier F5 ah ok4 intéressant pas je
sais pas mais fou 6 encore pe sûr 6 il
av toujours fou B7 ah je prends B7 du
coup ça ça c H4 malin c'est coup malin
hein prophylaxie hein prophylaxie encore
une
fois F4 alors F4 c'est un coup que
j'aimis enfin qui se regarde mais
visuellement ça me fait un peu mal aux
yeux à cause du Fou CIN c'est bourrin
mais en même temps j'ai peur pour mon
peut-être ah non j'isouis F5 c'est quand
même ça commence à être une menace quand
même assez jouer quand même elle te elle
elle te laisse tenjailler avec F5
5 peut-être VO au
cavalier C7
c'est il y aura toutes les découvertes
du monde peut-être du K C6 d'ailleurs
stouf je sais pas ouais ouais ouais mais
G5 j'aime bien ton coup un peu
g5iz au moins ben en C7 j'ai pas de cas
donc d'accord mais faire un coup c'est
kg5 H4 pour t'amener en H7 c'est assez
rigolo on le voit le cavalier est
vraiment après je pourrais jouer
H5 c'est fou là
mais effectivement c'est c'est une
position
bizarre pour provoquer les coups
bizarres c'est quand même un bel
avantage blanc je pense que c'est une
bonne opportunité pour essayer de de
mettre un deuxème à la suite et partie
CR par rapport à ce qu'elle avait
produit sur C par très là les deux
dernières H4 c'était tant moi j'avais
envie de le jouer aussi tu en penses
quoi ça pas mal c'est ça K6
et normal c'était normal la seule
problématique c'est qu'on a le pion F5
en l'air et du coup par ricocher le pion
D3 derrière donc là je joue dame 7 tant
pis rocher pas mal tu peux faire
des Roch on conna la cabane mais pas le
ricochet et là dans le même sty
cavalcade avec un cavalier mais là c'est
le ricochet du fou fou D6 et attends
mais elle a tout poussé là G4 G5 elle
est en train d'essayer de de corriger
son adversaire est-ce que fou F4 aussi
était pas mal hein j'aimais bien fou F4
Tran alors stabiliseer un peu attention
il y a les tour 8 qui commenc à arriver
elle a elle a trop envoyé là avec les
les blancs elle veut gagner directement
ok mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
comment estce tour 8 ouais tour 8
c'était le coup qu'on av envie de faire
fou F4 h G5 h G5 voà cavalier prend AE
aïe aïe fou F4 prise prise cavalier
prend et sur F elle a demandé trop à sa
position là mais c'est pas facile c'est
elle elle joue vite elle veut mettre la
pression elle est inspirée par moment et
par d'autres moments c'est quand même
beaucoup plus fait des gaff
ouais dangereux bah là elle a tenté le
tout pour le tout elle avait pas besoin
IFAN avait fait du mal à sa position
tout toute
seule
on voit d'ailleurs dans les dans les
ouvertures on voit que n'est plus aussi
active qu'avant parce que les ouvertures
sont fragiles et dans le jeu est
extrêmement forte mais les ouvertures
par moment comprension du je est là
c'est clair après c'est vrai que les
ouvertures quand tu es
inactif un peu truc tu es pas forcément
courant de
[Musique]
l'actualité ce se passeche quand même
mais c'est vrai que de là regarder la
théorie de manière assidue c'est encore
autre chose pour la gloire en plus si tu
ne joues
plus c'est quand même
difficile quand tu plusche tu reviens
et viag tourno ça
[Musique]
faittemp et donc là
maintenant doit voir sa position ne
ressemble plus à rien
elle a
cassé sa jolie position en balançant G4
G5 peut tout perdre parce que comment on
va faire sur le
clouage c'est quoi qu'est-ce que je
[Musique]
rate je peux
pas non ça marche pas c'est limite
perdu bon c'est très bien aussi he c'est
de pions de plus ouais en plus desass
pour ses pièces maintenant cavali qui
sont maintenant c'est
bien F6
juste
prend ave le ricochet du Fou D3 ouais
PR2 t
prend ça paraiss
sa plus de TR prise
doncett je
fouense je peux pas tenter fou B7 tant
pis stou ouais bon ok je prends alors
pour Esser d'être actif tu
voisce que j'ai
pas un
peu pour nous a une petite chance encore
quelque
chose second techque c'est dommage parce
que elle est pas loin je pense de
vraiment l'inquiéter parce qu'elle joue
extrêmement vite mais il y a quelques
petits bugs par moment qu'elle pourrait
je pense ne pas faire mais elle est dans
pas dans un super
jour j'ais bien tour D6 tour g6éit comme
ça intéressante
ouais l' fait comme
ça il y a moyen d'envoyer le pion ouais
5 à 6 B6 quelque chose comme
ça ça peut faire peur ça pe arriver très
très vite là Rica elle doit jouer à 5 de
mon point de vue assez vite ouais pour
mettre la pression je aussi échecess
d'aller manger le pion mais bon je pense
que c'est ouie de faire des menaces
rapid il faut y aller vite la 18
secondes
cavalier7
cavalier6 peuttre j'ai cavaler
C7 tu raison
j'ai pas le temps de faire je
peux mais ture
faire j'enlève le fou je' plus6
bienens
[Musique]
pasud mais c encore ouais ou allez tour5
je te joue tour5 un coup un peu bizarre
tu veux mettre pression ici c'est ça
ouais et balancer et sur F6 j'avais tout
re ma petite arnaque ah regarde ce
qu'elle a fait là c'est la même
il bien jouer tour 5
maintenant mais sur cavalier prend ici
je mat
ouais tour 5 c'est bien enfin c'est dans
l'esprit depuis tout à
l'heure est mal tempan elle attend juste
maintenant que
aïe aïe aïe
tourin pas une grosse menace
tourin B si ça marche pas hein ben non
parce que a prend B toujours je tiens
avec mon cavalier j'aurais beaucoup de
ah4 belle idée enferme le fou ça c'est
vraiment embêtant de se le prendre avec
secondes pr 5 pense que je pense que je
pense qu'elle va gagner avec les blanc
ah ouais bah sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
un feeling ça m l'air trop dur ce petit
B6 d'ailleurs propose une sorte de nul
tu vois ouais mais je pense qu' va
vouloir gagner
avec mais
bon regarde Mme coup commeb pe arriver
quoi mais laess laess comme tu l'avais
dit avec sacrif la pièce pour essayer
dement malin parce que elle a pas
récupéré le pion
à elle va tomber est-ce qu'elle va
tenter la finale fou cavalier avec
j'ai encore les tours de toute façon pas
vraiment prend G5 pr je crois que c'est
pas super à cause de d
RC écoute cétait le risque récompensé
ouais elle avait quand même tour sa
stratégie de la mettre mal au temps
c'est super maintenant il faut qu'elle
soit un peu plus constante et elle peut
faire craquer an qui l'a un petit peu
craqué toute seule ouais depuis la pause
depuis la pause et ben on a deux
victoires deux victoires à zéro de la
part de de Harik et sans doute deux
parties à cette cadence c'est assez
étrange je crois que ça existe eu prend
des 5 là ici le coup c'est quoi déjà
c'est pas non c'est ça jou euh j'ai déjà
vu
ça c'est pas fou B4 ah je sais plus
comment ça
joue c'est assz bizarre en fait oui mais
je je moi je connais Pasin je je te dis
je connais pas ici bien sûr les coup F 7
tout ça c'est normal 7 B4 mais cette je
l'ai déjà vu voilà je connais pasjà vu
euh je crois que prise il y a un truc ah
bah on espère parce que sinon c'est
bizarre je sais plus ce qu'il y a mais
il y a un truc sin sinon c'est le flop
c'est la déception moi je te le bouffe
je te le bouffe moi le pion allez je te
le bouffe comme je sais pas je je
regarde je sais pas je dirais tout B4
mais je me trompe peut-être ouais ouais
bon bah parce que si je prends prends
cavalier prend bon ok dam là j'ai dame 6
là j'ai dame 2 ouais je peux voilà tout
à fait donc prise fou b43 juste
rapidement je veux checker ouais parce
que c'était le jeu de prendre en D5 ah
c'est F B4 He4 ouais et puis bon pr tout
prend et l'activité
avec on donne tous nos pions mais on a
du jeu ok ça ressemble à une varand de
la scandin non
ouis oui exactement tout à
fait smdonne un peu ok dame D2
fan dans le doute elle se dit je joue
avec à3 ouais on sera les pièces bon il
y a la paire de fou quand même pour pour
les Noirs mais le manque d'espace fait
qu'on va museler cette petite paire de
fou donc c'est pas trop trop grave c'est
ce qu'elle a dû se dire la position est
fermée aussi donc c'est pas si grave est
tu me rends le fou j'aime bien quand
elle joue comme ça des petites variantes
un petit peu rares elle fait plaisir
ouais
vraiment des idées quoi à chaque fois
dans toutes les ouvertures a des idées
quoi c'est intéressant sur E4 ou elle
joue
5 espagnol avec cavalier7 avec avec G6
avec tour plein de petites lignes it
pareil ave h6 il y a plein de petites
lignes sur la française aussi plein de
trucs différents ici h c'est finalement
sur l'italienne traditionnelle qu'elle
s'est fait ultra dominer dans la
première partie sinon dans les
ouvertures ça quand elle joue un peu des
b tricky ça marche bien
oui puis en plus euh euh contre une j
comme IFAN pense c'est intéressant parce
que comme elle est plus trop euh euh
dans le monde des échecs tu vois la
théorie tout ça et ben je pense tu sors
un truc CR euh c'est intéressant parce
qu'elle s lui appé là déjà 1 minute 30
dans un début d'ouverture et puis en
plus elle pose un problème concret dame
à 5 c'est super embêtant on a
l'impression d'être dans winav qui a mal
tourné avec les Blancs
pas de pression sur G7
ou qu'est-ce qu'on joue là c'est
embêtanterou quand
même je vais prendre et
sur donc on va échanger lesam elle va
avoir une finale tout just correct parce
que les Noirs vont pouvoir travailler
sur la
colonne
je ouais ouais c'est c'est une des des
ouvertures intéressantes hein je parle
souvent des Quates fantastiques
ccilienne française Caro 45 on voit
qu'on a dans les parties de champion que
l'on peut voir beaucoup de ce genre
d'ouverture c'est6 est-ce que maintenant
il y a il y a prise cavalier prend
cavalier 5 qui deviennent menaant tout à
fait la française généralement quand tu
arrives à à casser son ça elle va bouger
la tour mais la 4 minutes 12 à à 2
minutes Arka si elle continue comme ça
elle peut prendre confiance elle était à
la à la pause vraiment pas favorite et
là elle se elle se remet bien et ça fa
mal tourn en plus hein stouf elle était
pas loin de craquer complètement je
pense comme quoi on voit que le le speed
chest le format est super on a on la
chance avec cette demi-finale et finale
j'avais peur qu'on assiste à un match un
peu fade avec une domination d'ouifan
outrageuse cétait le cas au départ et
c'est en train de s'inverser
complètement et en plus elle joue bien
reg elle joue vite et bien elle est
capable de le faire il se passe quoi
surprise qu'elle va les prendre qu'elle
va les prendre 5 fou B5 écheac fou B5
fou B5 c'est pas cl dout parce que la
tourage3 est
revenue je sais pas B5 fou D7 et
peut-être F4 je sais pas si ça marche he
non bon non c'est pas c'est pas génial
dame F4
ou ouais dam F4 c'est possible parce que
je ma tour qui défend donc en tout cas
elle voulait jouer pour les pour le les
compensations avec les Blancs et regarde
elle a fini par
elle a joué la petite finale ouais qui
s'est pas pris la tête hein elle a pas
essayé jou extrêmement vite elle se dit
si je tiens la boutique je fais roi E7
tour C8 et je travaille sur le pion C2
en plus elle a beaucoup de temps
d'avance donc peut-être qu'elle a pas
envie de prendre la tête pas envie de
doner de contrejeu essay deassurer la
partie
parce que cette position là on a
l'impression que c'est une domination
lente des noirs pendant très longtemps
et avec la pression du temps elle a
intérêt de se manier au Yifan parce que
sinon ça va faire comme des parties où
ah peut-être qu'elle va jouer pour F4 et
k G4 k F6
le P H6 qui peut devenir faible dans
cette position
attention F pe manœuvre mais bon il y a
il y a quand même la dame à surveillé
mais le pion H6 maintenant c'est pénible
trou6 c'est une idée
ve lui piquer peut-être le pion H6
c'est malin son idée hein tout à fait on
voit point d'inrogation alors qu'on
trouve ça sympa ouais cavalier B3 c'est
il y a un problème quand même sur sur le
le cavalier prend D4 elle a oublié
et et c'est dramatique en fait cavalier
B3 ouais dramatique que la bonne idée la
bonne idée ça tourne mal t prend je
menace qu'1 du coup j'ai pas le temps
[Musique]
id de prendre mais c'est pas facileprs
calier
[Musique]
plustir et sur
ici on peut avoir un fou C rapide
peut-être sur
C4
r minute maintenant je su peu quand
même calier
PR4 pas com je
r
plus
fou
f1ce qu'elle veut faire pourquoi pas G3
fou G2 peut-être fou G2 pour je F4 ouais
pourquoi pas intercepter cette Gago
ou f H3 aussi pour
[Musique]
provoquer et maintenant comment je fais
je bouge plus du tout avec toujours F2
F4 pour avoir t
r je pens une idée intéressante mais
pense G2 peut-être tout simplement roi3
ouais j'ai du mal à
bouger a 5
ESS de faire quelque chose il sait pas
quoi faire en faitic dans sa position
c'est un peuang en fait hein elle elle
bouge pas elle elle bouge pas le RO
bouge pas en fait je peux rien bouger là
il a
elle a raté pour moi la seule idée fou
G2 F4 pour faire tour H7 tour H8 en tête
tout à l'heure qui é intéressante
c'était fou H3 directement et sur
cavalier pr H6 tour H6 et T pr je vouis
faire fou F5 d'accord je pas échanger à
ce
momentlah et ma tour elle partait pas en
B6 ou quelque chose comme ça non non j'
7 j'avais t ok d'accord ah oui d'accord
et je me dis peut-être que je tour mais
ok peut-être que l'ordinateur il va te
dire que non mais mais visuellement ça
va intéressant ouais elle a raté elle a
vu trop maintenant elle se fait enfermer
le fou j'ai 3
F2 terminé terminé qui qui a fait un
signe de tête
là cas
précis F6 pas mal
aussi 6 ça pas de marcher encore tout va
être
bon5 le plus simple
abandon yes
qui s' sort bien ouais ou ou ou et là le
plus 3 et à nouveau
incroyable plus 2 he plus 2 pardon plus
2 et ce sera la dernière partie de ce de
ce format en 5+ une j'ai peut-être
poissé
euh poissé Arik j'ai annoncé le + 3
Stouff donc c'est
reparti un petit RTI G3 tranquille
ou c'est marrant avec avec les Blancs
elle est vraiment moins
ambitieuse c'est bizarre ouais c'est
vraiment super bizarre trouve des idées
de partout cl blanc juste tranquille
quoi c'est assz bizarre
elle veut un système un peu plan
[Musique]
plan qui aime bien regarder en bas
pour un trou de mémoire voà F F4 c'est
déjà concept
ouais
position 4
jou souvent transpose dans des positions
quand tu
faisu
[Musique]
dans on ferme le centre on attaque c'est
ça
donc
questionner4 cavalier4 pour
voir le 5 ici voilà c'est le
thématique là je sais pas lequel je
prends
CELI oui je pense pression làdessus
cavalier
F6 peut-être encore mieux ouis bien SAF
par je peux venir en B5 de toute façon m
case mais j'ai aussi j'ai pas F j'ai pas
B6 et là j'ai des problèmes là c'est
très intéressant de voir ce safice de
pion positionnal avec le fou G2 qui
domine le fou C8 comme dans une catalane
ouais
B6 cavalier C3 C3 D2 qu'on met le
cavalier dans position
de alors j'ai un élève au CH de Frane il
s'est pris un K3 comme ça une attaque
indienne en premier c'était pas mal il
s'est bien fait avoir donc même avec le
cavalier en C3 ça reste
jouable pr pr D4 j' ces positions pour
les blancs c'est un petit plus sur C4
tour cal 5
problème sur P
D5 mais touche pas
ben toujours un peu embêtant F6
peut-être pour prendre des cases avec
mon fou7 qui fait pas
grand-chose
F6 mal
entendu ça met une pression quand même
oui bien sûr pour avoir mes pions
pendant
après d's comment je dois réagir sur6
estce que je do manger jeis
je directement c'est TR c'est à peu près
égal sans doute
oui je sais pas comment réagir parce que
pr prise C3 il a D4 un jour à
voir en tout cas grosse pression a
tempants une nouvelle fois allez on voir
un peu comment elle joue je pense c'est
TR joue très bien pe lente je pense C3
va être le coup fou 3 elle pas toucher
la structure ah bien sûr surprise ce
serait je pense une grosse une grosse
gaffe he pression sur C5 ouais là il
faut défendre le P C5 alors C4 c'est un
coup thématique aussi hein ouais
mais dame D6 au choix ouais plutôt C4 je
pense j'aime moins dame D6 et là
ok surprise prendre de qui inquiétait
Arik donc C3 jouer et maintenant je va
quand même menacer ça donc là bon ok C4
avec cavalier à 5
pas mal ça vaensemble c'est un coup oui
c'est pour ça elle a retardé le coup C5
C4 pour se laisser cette
case c'est sympa avec les Noirs quand
même a réussi à enterrer un petit peu
les menaces blanches
ou c'est assez prometteur même pour les
Noirs ça l'air un peu plus facile à
jouer ou qu'est-ce qu'on joue icire
maintenant c'est embêtantand
C4 si joue B3 ça des une idée avec B3 ça
pourrait même des fois de revenir en C6
pour vir en B4 une fois qu'on Aang en
B4 aussi auss
C4 qui peut
être é
[Musique]
plus normal
maisre
mangali4
je vais peut-être prendre du Fou au
Stouff en D4 pour mais je mangerai
pareil je pense je mangais pareil je
faisais fou Mme
structure me paraî mieux de garder ces
pièces là parce que sinon le fou3 est
passif ah il y a eu
P c'est6 donc revient sur la case B4
comme on avait parti he j'aime bien
quand elle est comme ça on voit qu'elle
travaille
AC FO 6 tour 1 cavalier B4 c'est c'est
une menace hein peut-être qu'on va le
voir arriver là probablement FO 6
malheur fort mais tu vois c'est la
partie hein ça ça ça ah des fourchettes
deux partout et céit de cavalier B4 qui
a peut-être été raté par Harik
maintenant c'est très dur un fou5 il y a
cavalier moi je préfère avoir ce type de
position avec
euh le ça il a ça Inter le F F6 et le
fo3 échanger quoi
oui je suis d'accord bien sûr si pl
il prends intermédiaire je prends ouais
et tour de ça me fait peur hein ouais ça
fait peur bon il y a des trucs ça l' de
tenir
[Musique]
mais d'utant plus qu'il y a des dames C4
elle fait une grosse partie
d ah ouais elle sort ses pièces elle
attaque le pion elle garde les menaces
une
galèreour va jouer quand même vite c'est
dommage que elle soit fait enfoncer dans
le début comme ça attention heifan peut
reprendre un bel avantage pour ça faut
qu'elle convertisse cette position puis
y a une minute d'écart c'est beaucoup
dans toutes les parties he arrive à
jouer plus vite à Rica ouais c'est bien
pour le pour le Bullet c'est bien pour
le 3+ une aussi alors est-ce que après
il est possible qu'ouifan change de mode
hein change de braquetouf av quelque
chose de plus de plus rapide oui on l'a
vu he dans le match contre Cuk hein elle
était elle était plus lente quasiment
tout le temps et puis arriv en bullette
é hyper rapide et et elle joue hyper
bien quoi donc on va voir un petit peu
merica c'est vrai que bon faut voir mais
hier elle a fait un gros match et
puis aussi la fatigue de jouer un peu
tous les jours de pas avoir de pause
c'est ça peut
[Musique]
aussi dame B5 toujours ça aussi ça et ça
les idées de envahir vraiment les cases
blanches c'est un H6 ok
[Musique]
tranquille dame B5 avait fou F1 faut
qu'il faut vérifier hein ah oui oui oui
tout à
fait bien raison de
préciser bon c'est pas facile cependant
de faire la DIF ouais Mo j'aime bien dam
à 4 pas pourquoi un coactif qui euh peut
faire est-ce que je peux jouer tour à un
sauf pour enlever la pression
[Musique]
probablement probablement queoui et
c'est ouais pour enlever ta pression non
peut-être que je prends une fois en C1
pour mettre une pièce mineure en C1 pr
va prend çaou tour C8 forc pour empêcher
la forcette et tour C8 tour C8 voilà
menace attention F G4 attention F G4 ah
oui le petit euh ah il a c'est c'est pas
si facile ça reste quand même solide
chez les
Blancs quelque chose voilà dame C6 c'est
la même idée sauf qu'on se prend pas fou
G4 ouais ça mieux attention 40 secondes
quand même pour
an toujours un peu la même la même
problématique réussir à jouer
convenablement sans s'écrouler à la
pendule fou
de tour C8 G4 c'est ça trop
fort
exact al je vous rappelle pour le chat
on a un petit décalage avec vous on a 20
secondes de de délai on voit vos message
20 secondes
après les avoir écrit donc si on vous
répond avec un peu plus normal il a
toujours ce petit délai qui est antiich
par rapport à par rapport au jeux et
cetera allez cette fois j'échange le fou
et je joue tour C8 de toute façon un
jour va falloir s'occuper de cette
tour donc là ça a buggé ou c'est moi
ouais je pense ça elle est pas tombé
autant non non non on on on a pas les
coups en fait ah terrible chez moi
attends je vais essayer de d'actualiser
un petit
refresh non on a vu la pendule
s'arrêter pourtant elles sont là elles
sont connectées elles jouent est-ce
qu'on peut voir dans les dans le dans
les lunettes de ou fan peut-être les
coups qu'elle a joué mince mince mince
est-ce qu'on arrive à voir dans le
reflet
ou là là attends attends ça arrivit oh
là là tu as réussi à nous faire une
accélération Stouff non j'ai rien fait
du tout c'est l'ordinateur qui a qui a
tout fait tout seul donc il s'est passé
plein de choses pe revenir rapidement
très très très vite ouais parce que 15
secondes contre 45 elle a piqué la paire
piqué la paire et travailler le pion E3
mais en même temps il y a le pion pion
D5 donc les noirs sont peut-être un
petit peu mieux et encore c'est pas
facile hein de dire parce que le pion E3
il est solide ouais
cavalier F4 hyper bien placé est-ce
qu'on peutire
G5 G5 peut être une idée mais chez les
blanc un peu du mal à voir comment on
joue parce que j'ai pas d'entrée j'ai
pas trop
cascoupp en fait à cause des problèmes
cause la de fou
advers bienche truc
ça mieux 10 secondes
[Musique]
ou juste la
pare
dur complètement dame C3 peut-être ou
dame B5 mais bon
c'estg on va voir sans doute un match
nul après peut-être dame
C6 G5 attention pas je pensais qu'elle
voulait jouer pour nul maintenant
qu'elle a fait les
échanges
[Musique]
après prise
priseement ça va faire nul he ramène le
roi et pas grand chose à faire attention
à ce P des 5 quand même attention
mat F5 ah mais tous les pion sur blanc
mais le roi blanc il peut passer quand
même
attentionin attention à la case ouais ça
va être dur de passer quand même TR dans
ces position ouais ça va êre dur mon
passe
pas peut-être par par ici mais
je5 ah faut surveiller de l'autre côté
là là le
ouais mais j'ai toujours ça en l'air le
P F5 en l'air donc je pouvais pas par
tout ce que je voulais jou ok nul dans
cette partie et ça y est on va et ça va
être la fin de ce set avec 5 non 53 dans
ce match je vais vous mettre le score à
jour pause de quelques minutes pour les
joueurs joueuses avant d'entamer 1 heure
de 3+ 1 lors du du prochain la prochaine
portion le prochain 7 d'ailleurs on fera
on fera une petite prédiction si vous
voulez pour ce deuxème set donc là on a
vu 53 pour oifan en 5+1 mais on a vu
queifan avait toujours une minute voire
2 minutes de retard dans chaque partie
donc on va maintenant comment elle va
s'adapter au 3 va jouer va jouer assez
propre et là elle va jouer un peu plus
là il faut jouer plus vite de toute
façon
et voilà donc du coup voilà salut ciel
bleu C ble qui arrive pour la pub il va
être
content on apprécie la pub hein tu
gagnes la pub c'est pour toi ciel bleu
yes donc je vous dis à tout de suite
allez à tout suite après une petiteage
de pub et puis euh à tout de suite pour
le 3+
[Musique]
yes c'est où la
pub
[Musique]
de retour je crois que les gens tout le
monde sait maintenant que Bado le
principal
principal de TCOM si seulement euh alors
les parties n'ont pas commencé les files
sontc absente mais elles vont arriver
dans quelques instants on va commencer
le 3 + 1 donc 1h de 3 + 1 avec pour
l'instant un score de 53 en faveur de
ouifan et pendant la pause une fois
n'est pas coutume on discuter au gazeuse
vous l'aurez compris oui je je vous
disais que j'avais bouteille de sa film
que j'aime énormément voilà je suis très
fan et je viens de la remplir et euh
trop bien à partir de demain je joue le
tournoi de de Kill Kenny bon qui démarre
que le vendredi mais je pense que je
parlerai moins
d'ogazeuse assez festif je crois que
la-base c'est bon l'Irlande c'est quand
même connu pour pour ses ses bières hein
bien sûr même dans le Blade où on va
kken ça existe donc
il y a la bière du du
bled ouais c'est un tour qui est quand
même depuis très longtemps depuis de
nombreuses années un un tournoi un peu
incontournable he pour pour no Jeurs
français euh on a bon je sais que je
connais très bien fa bienen libki par
exemple il part chaque année avec
Sébastien ma math cornet il y a
peut-être d'autres enc oui bien sûr ouis
ouais qui est déjà déjà sur place
apparemment Libye dans le groupe
WhatsApp c'est ce que j'ai pu voir ok tu
par dem repérage ouais ouais ouais toi
tu pars demain ouais demain demain matin
avec donc on arrive enfin pour ma part
j'arrive le jeudi vers début
d'après-midi et j'ai mon capitaine
d'équipe jeannoël Rif qui m'attend déjà
qui sera là vers midi tu vois on se
retrouve et du coup dès 14h on visiter
tu le vois à Paris non non non on se
rejoint à Dublin d'accord on se rejoint
à Dublin parce que prend chacun nos vols
respectifs et Dublin K c'est
c'est c'est 1 heure de
bus ou 1 he je sais pas enfin quelque
chose comme ça donc je sais pas c'est
bus s train je vais voir sur place stouf
mais comme il y a des habitués tu vois
je vais me laisser porter au niveau du
c'est quand même dommage parce qu'avec
ton avec ton ton si bon anglais
ahà
débrouiller B déjà quand je vais arriver
je serai tout seul tu sais c'est
toujours assez marrant
quoi pourrais faire profiter tout le
monde de de cela B oui tu met si tu veux
c'est très bien que tu fasses tu tu
mettes un un petit
Stream qui suiv vraiment ton voyage
quand vraiment on voit tout ce que tu
fais bon mais c'est difficile à
organiser techniquement et comme je suis
ni last de la technique ni l de
l'anglais c'est
[Musique]
compliqué alors les filles se prépar 1
heure de 3+ 1 à partir de maintenant
ouais on va attendre que les parti soit
lancer chez moi c'est pas encore le
cas
Etik qui qui va devoir faire fort ici de
points de
retard c'est parti
ouais ça respecter une certaine
physionomie mais elle a réussi à mettre
la pression autant donc si elle joue
aussi bien en avec le en en mettant la
pression autant ouais ouais elle peut
vraiment faire quelque chose à voir si
ouifan est capable de jouer avec le même
niveau de qualité un peu plus vite pour
ne pas trop baisser le niveau de qualité
je pense c'est vraiment à IFAN de
s'adapter euh à la nouvelle cadenceelle
arrive à s'adapter à la nouvelle cadence
une fois favorite parce qu'au vu des
parties elle a quand même été devant
quasiment tout le temps et euh donc donc
voilà mais elle est un peu lente donc si
elle arrive à s'adapter à ça ça c'est
bon augur pour pour fan
regarde grande variété avec D6 F5
surprendre chaque partie
chanormémentér ça
pas visu Enie jouer
d de truc mais comment tu
réag B3 est-ce que j'ai le droit de
faire le Gumble
moi je regardais cavalier je crois ou
pas
peut-être mais même cavalier F6 bon F77
bon elle doit connaître hein pour jouer
des coups comme ça ça s'improvise pas
trop casse
gueulereura jou sur sur D4 pensez au
style de Christian Bauer qui est capable
de comme ça de jouer des ouverture un
peu bizarroïde et avec beaucoup de
talent ouais
ouais faut être créatif hein pour jouer
C ouvertures parce que c'est4 cré
aussi des B5 de mettre la pression
directe
ouais c'est logique G5 dans l'esprit
aussi est logique B si si tu as commencé
par
là engagé dans le
cou j'ai St je joue H4 c'est dans
l'esprit aussi avec cavalier G5 derrière
de me faire enfermer mon cavalier je
pensais même cavalier pr 5 mais bon ça
pas l' peutêtre génial mais regarde
c'est parti sou allez H4 là la prise ah
dommage j'espéré H4 Mo le me H4
clairement clair possible cavalier prend
prend
h ça quand même pas l'air génialette
histoire est-ce que CIT pas M faireprend
DPR juste peut-être qu'elle veut faire
C6 C7 St on a vu d'autres ouisen
F mais
bon en tout cas la volonté d'Ar c'est
pas jouer est H4 et sur
G4 prend
g8end4 là je fais mon petit génie là bon
la elle aime pas ce que je fais mais
regarde moi je des
truc truc c'est peut-être un peu artique
mais il a des idées un
peu bon C6 C7 le
[Musique]
jeu j'aime bien elle a le même postulat
que d'habitude c'estàd qu'elle a réussi
encore au niveau du temps alors
peut-être la position c'est elle est un
peu moins bien mais c'est une position
tellement
bizarre que ça donne envie au blanc de
réfléchir pour conserver leur avantage
mais c'est pas facile
ou encore une
foisance
d'avance8 ça fait peur franchement
je commence à tour G8 complètement
impossible s faut pas qu'on oublie ok ok
moi je l'ai
oublié moii moiussi ça va vite bizarreas
pas habit tu sa bien
sr tu dis ouais voil est-ce que j'ai le
droit de jouer le cavalier pr C3 un peu
bizarre peut-être mais bon il y a ça tap
sur partout faire
7 et 6 ou Ro et rouge pe-être plus
classique
ouais je comprends qu'il faut il faut
prendre des risques mais bon
Mo fautut se calmer ouais c'est un peu
trop je pense le roi il est qu des8 sune
pièce cavalier F6 cavalier F6 pourquoi
pas c'est un coup candidat quand même si
la joue n'aime pas trop c'est pas grave
et ro C7 on envie de le faire quand
même attention à K4 quand même sur roi
C7 il faudra trouver un
coup la petite menace sur le pion E5 ça
peut vraiment maintenant qu'on a replacé
la dame en E2 ça peut être
désagréable elle a pas aimé cette dame
en
E2 faut y avoir peutêre C4 c'est le
moment de de jouer un peu plus vite
voilà et il y a le problème
sur sur E5 et F4 attention à ce roi qui
est de plus en plus fragile ouais le
centre qui t T1 tour1 là avec des idées
de fou prend F4 donc serait tour 8 et
non fou
G7 tour D1 pour la case D6 D6 menace
tour D8 wouh et alors ouais bah là là
c'est
ouais il y a un peu de craquage et
c'est dommage pourik qui faisait une
partie quand même assez sympa en terme
pratique et tour c'est quand même mal
senti d'ailleurs ça va lui coûter du
temps partie vraiment sympathique en
plus et là tour8 alors que la menace de
tour D1 c'est k D6 c'est un peu bizarre
d'ailleurs ça lui coûte du temps elle
joue fou G6 elle va croquer IFAN et
maintenant on va peut-être chercher le
chos alors c'est comment on met le fou
C1 il y a un peu de réflexion par
rapport à ça est-ce que je joue fou des
deux fou1 fou F2 et je double
ouais c'est
joué simple j'ai envie il fallait allit
se poser la question de la priorité
c'est le fou C1 fou1 sans doute là à
tour d'accord je peu étonné moi aussi
préfér fou1 tour D1 aussi bien tu peux
tour D11 voilà c'est bien aussi ce que
ce que tu dis c'était pas le plan mais
que je voyais mais ça marche aussi
c'està-dire faut s'occuper du foot cas
noir d'AM F2 ça travaille à 7 ça pose
une
question et il y a 18 secondes faut se
manier surtout dans cette position ouais
mais là ça va il y a que là sont à prè
égalité il y a pas de retard il y a eu
un gros retard au début mais finalement
qui n'a pas été et pensez bien activer
vosot dernière pièce qui joue pas allez
on fait 7 là c'est vraiment AUG de la
part des noirs sur F3 il F2
peut-être F F7 il y a eu
ok maintenantise ouais ça a l'air
d'aller quand même faut quand même
réussir à à empêcher ce truc là
[Musique]
gag prendre un PR et je prends le
cavalier
term qui avait fait une ouverture comme
elle le fait si souvent avec la noir
très intéressante ouais elle a des
bonnes idées mais le problème c'est le
tour 8 qui est venu gâcher le le fait en
plus elle avait plus de temps et il y a
souvent ce genre de coup un petit début
de Londres on nous l'avait pas fait
jusqu'à présent ouais elle mené de TR
points maintenant dans ce match et c'est
difficile là il il va falloir enchaîner
des victoires
E3 c'est coup qu'on
[Musique]
joue6
h
on sur
vaouer
des on pique le fou et l'attaque de
minorité C j'ai fait une vidéo YouTube
il y a pas longtemps sur ce sujet là SAF
pour lire les structure de pion et là
montrer que bah les Blancs jouent sur la
case5 et les Noirs B5 B4 les types
d'attaque de minorité qu'on retrouve
aussi dans le gambidam inversé de la
vente d'échange bon c'est très très
simple de de lire la
structure F5 a été
joué peu
bizarre voilà tempo
généralement mais j'ai envie de jouer G5
g5ut prend G3 cavalier4 je peux dire
qu'on va pas rigoler avec maintenant que
j'ai vu que c'était point
d'interrogation je peux vous dire que ça
me donne envie d'aller là-dedans
ouais là R a fait commence accusé le
coup ça peut être vite une poubelle
elle a pas raté en plus oh là là là
là ou dame3 ah cavalier E4 c'était
terrible non c plus fort des de même
celle ça cavalier 2 oh là cavalier je ça
va être abandon direct encore une fois
pour
an enfin pour a et qui
euh assez marrant la tête qu'elle a fait
ave avec ses doigts là faisait je sais
pas ce qu'elle faisait
ouais aïe aïe aïe
qui veut tellement jouer vite qui en
fait bon je pense que cqué là par
rapport à hier tu vois en fait hier on
l'a dit hein parce qu'ier que dans le
match qui a eu hein contre Catarina Lano
il quand même eu beaucoup de
Gal et on disait que si elle jou pareil
contre
oifan ça ça sentait mauvais et en fait
elle joue vite pour mettre la pression
mais mais elle fait plein de gaffe quand
même ouais il arrive pas à tenir il y a
toujours un moment où ça craque ouais le
problème c'est que contreifan ça ça
passe pas quoi ça passe pas et même hier
contre catarinaan qui ça pe pas passé
non plus mais hier Catarina elle a fait
un petit match quand même on disait oui
oui c'est ça elle a pas aussi bien joué
que d'habitude c'est ça donc euh
est dangereuse harica quand même mais
c'est vrai que là trop de craquage elle
est très dangereuse mais euh mais mais
elle fait beaucoup
d'erreur beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs
tour de
moins c'est cher petit rock voilà et
puis maintenant on va pouvoir convertir
tranquillement
tour F1 tour F3 abandon ok allez h
suivante donc là ça fait qume maintenant
pour pour la Chinoise an
[Musique]
beaucoup confiance en plus va va suivre
côtéan donc plus de fantaisie côté Harik
elle se met en
mode je joue mes ouvertures presque
normal maintenant je suis pas si sûr de
ce choix là j' bien jqu à présent ave
les noir ce qu'elle ce qu'elle faisait h
HM et bon on en a marre de d'enchaîner
les bulles quoi c'est ça aussi le truc
là ça fait
beaucoup est très sévère
ouais 73
[Musique]
mais pourtant elle a tout des bonnes
position r avec les noir ouais ouais tu
es pas loin de quelque chose mais euh
elle ose beaucoup hein elle ose beaucoup
avec les Noir et très très peu avec les
Blancs et
euh mais bon elle met beaucoup elle
beaucoup de pression a temps mais
malheureusement elle fait elle commet
trop d'erreur alors 6 il y a F pr le 6
dam B3 mais après après le petit rock je
pense pas vraiment on a dame C8 toute
façon oui mais je pense même dame D7 en
fait ou oui bien
sr tu vois il y a toujours c pas oui
c'était mat mat à la dame ça ça c'est
Chac mat à la dame
voilà donc mais bon dam au pire des cas
si tu vois queas pas le ch comme tout à
l'heure cavalier
G3 cavalier G3
et on jouera pour D4 prochainement KG3
un jeu pour D4 et les Noirs jouent pour
D5 dame D7 jouer et là du coup D4 pas
mal il y a une fourchette qui est
menacée sur D4 on va forcer un peu B3
j'ai l'impression fa prend H3 on voit
beaucoup de joueurs amateurs qui se
posent la question de faire ça dans
certaines positions c'est très pertinent
mais dans ce CASL fa vos pièces arrivent
et après D4 les blancs coupent le fou A7
le visàis qui aurait pu faire très mal
pour avoir des d pr G3 mais là ce n'est
pas possible cavalier
tranquille ou c'est ça très bien joué
rames du monde à la fte en défense et ça
marche bien ouis il man piè noir en plus
JIS j'arett mon
petit donc a
rien non
OK
jou
là voilà préférer cela que D4
directement les deux sont
intéressants et c'est un petit plus
blanc est-ce qu'on prend une fois est-ce
qu'on joue5 des choses comme ça il va
falloir essayer de de sauvegarder le
centre parce que là ça ça semble
difficile de jouer avec les deux pions
isolé sans trop elle vote pour ça quand
même F7 on peut peut-être jouer prise 5
et F3 attendou3 d'abord moi j'aurais jou
prise 5 pour essayer de
crés pense c'était très intéressant pour
avoir une partie simple sur long par la
structure un peu contre contre champur
par
ée la dernière r du
championnatit comme ça
noir contre firouja qui Ava réussi à
aller manger les pions pas évident en
fait l'avantage de de pions doubl là
c'est que ça donne des cases pour le
noir une D4 une g aussi en H4 mais
l'incovvénient c'est que les son isolé
doublé donc c'est bizarre la lecture de
la structure de pion là
de t
prend4 il a réussi à mettre la tour à 7
donc ça veut dire qu'elle va gagner la
colonne tour imaginer tour D4 dans cette
position
rentrer là peut-être qu'on va avoir tour
tour on trip et on triple avec les
Blancs tour des4 et le petit avantage de
la colonne c'est une position quand même
très dure à jouer pour pour les Noirs C
qui pour les blancs est-ce que je peux
tenter t prend des4 et dame B1 je crois
pas se trou sur tour D1 parce que je
vais gagner à de mais je vais me faire
rentrer en 7e rangée peut-être que
peut-être que vu
le vu le score elle doit essayer de
faire quelque chose mais mais c'est vrai
que G4 ouais c'est ça préfère tour F8
elle tient en 7e
elle a joué très vite une nouvelle fois
j'avais pas trop regarder la pendule
mais on voit que c'est une belle
démonstration d'Arik avec la pièce noire
elle a joué assez vite
[Musique]
ouais et surtour surtout lesour F7 je
pense à priori le roi qui peut aller en
H7 ouais à 5 B6 pour c'est le setup
qu'elle va adopter pour essayer de jouer
l'égalité et je pense pense que c blanc
ça peut être G3 tour F4 aussi ouais on
genre de système comme ça G2 voilà alors
est-ce que on pouvait tenter la finale
avec Dame
F3 dame F3 prise prise tour F7 ouais
tour D7 je jouer tour B3
ouais c'est intéressant en tout cas pour
essayer de forcer un peu les choses par
que là je suis un petit peu dominé alors
que avec Dame F3 je pouvis peut-être
m'activer tour F4
proposé très intéressant h peut-êtrem
dire mais je suis pas sûr H5 parce
qu'apprès il faud garder un œil sur ce
pion tout reprend F8 avec Dame F3 prends
F dame F3 prend dame C4 aussi d'idée
mais elle veut garder un peu les pièces
à 27 secondes he pas facile ouais et où
prend le dessus ouais ça y est là en
en en 3+ 1 c'est un petit peu difficile
il y a jpet qui qui dit que
t de mais non mais j'y pas la stou c'est
c'est incessamment qu' va passer il a
rempli les conditions mais la FIDE a
fait le Congrès un peu tôt en C en
juillet dernierou c'est ça ouais je suis
passé mettre c'était quand que je suis
passé mettre
exactement je suis passé mettre fin
juillet j'ai rempli toutes mes condition
fin juillet et le Congrès a eu lieu
mi-juillet j'ai raté cons c'est raté le
congrès à à une semaine et donc faut
attendre le prochain congrès pour être
validé et le prochain congrès a lieu
mid-décembre donc voilà dans un peu
moins d'un mois normalement tu auras
vraiment le le type actualisé j'ai pas
tu nous dis si St doit changer du coup
parce qu'eectivement voilà en fait tu
sais que de base moi quand j'ai j'ai
fait mon premier stream al je sais plus
quel nombre c'était mais le premier
stream que j'ai fait après passé
I et ben moi j'avais tout tout préparé
tout toutes les scènes et j'ai marqué
mare feed tu vois parce que pour moi
j'étais encore mare feed j'ai pas encore
enfin sur le site de la feed j'ai pas
encore tout ça et le problème c'est
j'étais devancé par chesscom FRR sur un
post sur un post Facebook ou Instagram
je sais plus et qui m'avait donné le
titre de Emy donc j'ai vu que il est
marqué je sais plus quel événement
commentc sur comm fa par le M et j'ai
dit bon tu m'as spoil et du coup bah
maintenant je mets à chaque fois parce
que voilà mais obligé mais à la base à
la base je mais bon oui ça arrive
bientôt d'ailleurs j'avais j'avais
envoyé un petit mail à chesscom pour
leur demander s'il pouvait me changer
mon titre
etoui et il m'ont répondu quand tu seras
official sur la Fed on mettra j'ai dit
d'accord
merci c'est génial donc bon j' rien la
faire mais bon ils ont raisonin il y a
plein de gens
quio tu imagines moi je je tiens ça y
est j'ai j'ai j'ai fait ma troisème
norme s'il te plaît et en fait c'est pas
vrai Mo il faudrait que je demande le
titre de grand maîre à chesscom en
Argand la photo du Top 16 où il s'était
trompé il m'aimé un petit j d'ailleurs
je je l'ai vu tempo hein je l'ai vu
tempo la photo j'ai j'ai ça a plu je
peux dire que ah oui moi ça m'a beaucoup
tech press on a bien profité mais c'est
c'est c'est pas très étonnant
le le coup le coup de génie ça c des peu
un peu troll en plus toi tu as quand
même TR de GM donc euh donc bon enfin tu
vois tu es tu es là
quoi ouais ça fait bien plaisir deer
ouais tu sais on aime beaucoup en
d'échec le troll c'est c'est national
hein c'est le sport un peu
national cavali C3 le retour et B4 une
très bonne réputation normalement pour
les Noirs c'est bizarre qu'elle soit
laissé tenter planter
çaan parce que la structure est quand
même assez agréable après faut faire
attention la conversion est pas facilem
ouais normalement c'est quand même pas
mal pour pour les blancs tout
ça qui mais la première fois la première
fois tu as mis et du coup du coup bon ok
je changé quoi mais moi j'avis j'avais
commencé les scènes avec
FM bon après ça pas grandchose he
nous non mais c'est une satisfaction
personnelle parce que on investi
tellement s sur les échecs le fait que
tu passesi bah c'est c'est quand même
bah c'est un invissement quoi exactement
surtout quand on sait ce qui s passé
récemment tu sais tu t'es quand même
accroché alors que tu as eu un vent
contraire alors que c'était quasiment
fait bah c'est c'est bien quand ça se
passe j'étais j'étais j'étais à un point
de passé mtre et j'ai joué contre un
1600 et j'ai perdu
quoi et ça c'est c'est c'est ça
franchement euh vous raconte pas comment
j'ai passé la soirée derrière mais
euh franchement c'était Durin au moral
c'est pu c'est pas la première fois que
j'ai des trucs comme ça parce que j'ai
eu plein de fois de 90 95 j'ai eu plus
lesos et à chaque fois à chaque fois
systématique dès que je suis à à une
partie tu peux ch
la600 c'était quand même cool quoi enfin
il y avait oui oui non mais j'ai perdu
tout seul j'ai perdu tout seul j'ai en
plus je l'ai mis en dat note j'ai j'ai
tout bien fait j'ai j'ai bien pris mon
temps j'ai il fait une belle partie hein
pour le coups il y a une petite pression
qui qui se met en place évidemment Voon
là IFAN rate complètement sa partie elle
est mal au temps et la position enfin
elle a rien menacéou les P passés qui
vont qui vont arriver et cavalier 4 a
été joué une erreur selon la
jauge un 16 qui avait été de 2150 pour
le coup euh il a vraiment été 2150 le
gars il y a quelques années et euh et
euh il t repdu mais il a fait une bonne
partieis
me mais bon à la fin il avait 2 minutes
moi j'en avais 10 et je suis pris une
fourch coup mais c'est pas une
fourchette c'est un cavaler pr je suis
cloué et il
m'attaque et en
plus gros je perd un pion une qualité et
jeis oigé de changer
toutesèour
moi ouais tu peux rien faire quo j'ai
failli gagner autant d'ailleurs a a a il
a joué deux coups avec une seconde don
dont un avec 0 0 quelque chose qu
j'avais envie de faire bouger la table
dès qu'il va bien sûr tremblement de
terre mais non ok alors comment elle a
réussi à ne pas gagner ça j'ai j'ai
tourné la tête là
sou et du coup alors queik je la voyais
gagner cette partie je vois que c'est
plus clair la pression autant que Ben
qu'elle plein plein d'erreurs elle est
pas du tout euh précise je comprends pas
le dernier coup juste stouf est-ce que
tu peux m'expliquer c'est c'est quoi ok
ouais donc là elle avait un avantage et
puis elle a laissé son adversaire
ressortir ouais mais c'est ici en fait
qu'il y a eu un truc il s'est passé
quelque chose ici là ici sur A5 il s'est
passé quelque chose la JA elle elle
m'annonce ça qui était avec cavaler
prend D5 ah oui un un petit B7 aussi
même B7 aussi pas
mal prend5 tout le
tempsion prend j'ai j'ai prend B4 ouais
menace tour C8 ouais d'c bon c'est quand
même pas si simple encore c'est tactique
on sentait que elle travaillait très
bien Rica et etan elle se bat et est-ce
qu'elle va pas la retourner complètement
avec ses 25 secondes parce que
maintenant le pion B passé elle est la
seule à pouvoir gagner
ouais mais la finale attention aussi la
finale le pion qui peut être
j en fait c'est le roi qui va être actif
c'est risque là normalement pour et en
plus la structure qui est sur sur case
noire qui peut faire fixer tout à fait
là on a peur là j'ai qui pe AR va être
obligatoire
ok du coup B3 et ro A2 non j'ai
l'impression que je passe non oui oui
tout à fait je pensais qu'elle bloquer
cette possibilité là non non je pense
obligatoire
H4 juste
çai
[Musique]
plus
abandon la course mais j' beaucoup trop
t ça va êre
dur
est va s'en sortir
avec
plus
pour beaucoup beaucoup trop dur je pense
ici la
française sor maintenant va jouer
extrêmement positionnelle hein on la
voit Arou de tout façon de toute façon à
chaque fois elle joue ses positions
tranquille mais là elle avait
complètement raté quand même son
ouverture ou fan donc elle s'en sort
quand même très
bien
et Cal B3 F3 C3 j'aime bien ce qu'elle
fait on est reparti pour une petite vis
ouais fa 3 qui empêche un peu
C5 est-ce qu'il y a une pause dans le 3+
1 pour se remettre de ses émotions pour
Arika et essayer de revenir
je crois que je sais pas jusque là nous
on n pas eu de pause parce qu'il avit 50
minutes et il faisait pas mais
normalement dans les speed ch avec une
heure et ben
c'est il y a bien une pause fer du
bien bon a peut-être réussi quelque
chose est que les blancs vont jouer à4
ici
mais A4 je pense était le coup des Noirs
donc là tu dois faire
ça de donc ça
m'ens
pour
Mang
cou
changer mais tu sa
pas changer libè option a
C5
de de
faire pas vu une idée un peu bizarroïde
est-ce que un moment je peux faire fou
B6 pour essayer de cravater le pion à5
ah manger comme ça ouais bas
ouis et F B6 tout de suite on menace pas
grandchoserière intéress je fais tour
tranquille oh j'ai TR ok pour éviter
ouais
bonempêche les fous de se mêler un peu
la
bataille et j'ai TR pour juste normal
hein bon en tout cas les blancs c'est
bien elle se prend pas la tête et elle
arrive en plus à conserver euh au niveau
du temps de belles perspectives ouais
ouais t jouer très vite ça pourrait être
logique pas de de raison j'aurais mis
l'autre elle met la tour a pourquoi pas
ouais cavalier 6 reste qu Mme une idée
pour piquer peut-être la paire de fou
c'est pas que j'aime beaucoup cavalier 6
F prend tout prend et ramener l'autre
tour ici et mettre la pression avec ce P
bien aussi ouaisand le centre est stable
on prendre l'espace sur les
ailes c'est vraiment vraiment mais dans
toutes les finales de tour ce plus
instinct va être un problème Cali si
j'aim vraiment bien quoi d'ailleurs on
peut faire tour 8 aussi à certain moment
stouf tour 8 c'est un peu embêtant parce
que tour tu veux dire c'est quoi ouais
c'est la partie he c'est la partie ah
ouais et maintenant STAC il y a tour là
peut-être mais j'ai cavalier ici
cavalier C5 VO bien B4 d'abord histoire
de ou B4 aussi ouais j'aimais bien B4
comme ça tu pouvais rien faire mais bon
ok c'est analogue
ouais en fait B3 de suite maintenant
ouais ou j'aime bien empêcher quand même
tout ça K5 aïe aïe aïe mais bon KAV B7
K5 voilà c'est ce qu'elle fait et KAV
fou complètement j'ai r C3 et B3 elle
trouve tout là ouifan ouais ça va être
dur he ça va être dur la machine est
lancée là ouais puis on sent que chez
Harik s'est grippé elle a pris un énorme
coup au moral ouais qui peut la sauver
c'est peut-être passé en mode bullette
mais la dernière demi-heure de 3+ 1 peut
être dur et puis tu peux pas rattraper
forcément 5 points en bullette ouais
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est c'est
quand même chaud quand ton petit B3 est
tentend salut
TRX salut à
toi alors ro C3 at joué et maintenant on
va faire tour 1 au prochain coup je
pense il y av sur tour 1 juste avant
mais maintenant tour 1 bon c'est trop
stable c'est facile à jouer pour les
blancsid je pousser mon pion un jour je
peux m faire tour à un et pousser le P
en fait exact qu'est-ce que tu fais
juste je sais pas quoi faire avec les
Noirs justement et je vois cette poussée
du pion a qui va grandir l'avantage des
blancs une nouvelle fois puis qu'est-ce
que ça doit être dur ces matchs de speed
chess quand on commence à prendre l'eau
hein Souf on le sait ou horble pas
facile il faut rester au contact pour au
moins menacer quelque chose m sur roi B6
il B4 à
5 c'est trop facile à jouer pour les
blancs en fait il eu cavalier D7 est-ce
que maintenant on faerit pas B4 ou même
cavalier ici bon il y a quand même tour
tour de attention C B3 c'est pas mal B4
c'est nickel B4 mais B4 c'est pas mal
t'empêche 5 et tu te gardes la CE pour
plus tard maintenant tuas 5
ou même roi des deux est pas pas débile
pour me faire cavalier B3 et cavalier C5
ouais là on a envie de faire A5 aussi
hein c'est le cou A5 aussi ouais même B5
c'est ce qu'elle veut peut-être essayer
de faire r les de maintenant on va
s'enlever
elle joue qu'av les B3 il y a plus tour
de maintenant donc elle a bien raison de
48 secondes et sur tour C8 maintenant il
y aura r les de ouais tout à fait et là
vraiment j'ai aucune idée ah peut-être
tour 4 au moin alle T 2 tour 4 C3
peut-être ici est-ce que je peux jouer
cavalier D4 mais je étais je viens je vi
de D4 avec mon cavalier c'est peut-être
bien qu' D4 c'est peut-être très bien
mais roi D2 ça m'ava bien moi sur ça ça
juste allez ouais c'est ce qu'il faut
pas trop le problème en fait le pion bah
non tout tout est bien en fait hein le
truc c'est que tous tes pions sont sur
noir tu as un foot blanche bon cavalier
cont mauvais fou elle avait fait une
master cl dans ce type de position dans
un pion isolé et ben là elle a un pion
de plus donc c'est pire que tout à
l'heure et Harik d'ailleurs elle est mal
au temps pour une des premières fois de
tout le match elle est mal a temps elle
accuse le coup vraiment cavaler C5 A5
voilà A5 tour 1 bon tour 1 C3 cavaler C5
en plus Mo tour4 maintenant peut-être
que j'aiess bon il y a 6 qui fait peur
j'ai plus c TR à cause de F ah non si t
devant ouais faut faire attention bon
maintenant qui C5 ah D4 ok moi j'aurais
voulu empêcher ro B7 avec C C5 F F5
peut-être faire très simple maintenant
je vais rentrer c'est3 C3 comme ça je
suis tranquille
a gagné la la colonne E très mécanique
he vous voyez roi des4 C3 voilà c'est
c'est encore une fois un très très bon
Très bonne technique he à 6 on va
pousser le pion à à 6 à 7
F4 c'est très bien aussi on a tout
fixé il y a plus de jeu on peut elle va
revenir en C5 elle va faire A6 on
tricote elle a droit allez pousser le
pion là voilà mais elle a très très bien
fait hein franchement pour la conversion
technique regardez cette partie c'est
vraiment terrible jeis bien jouer un
petit tour à pour menacer à 7 voilà
c'est c'estes choses faites elle voit
bien les choses
laisser le pion ici peut-être un petit
peu histoire de continuer à pousser
ok elle a décidé de d'envoyer le le coup
C4 pou attendre un petit peu pour faire
des tests et perdu autant ah ouais mais
bon la position été de toute façon
difficile et c'est la pause encore entre
les joueurs vous av aimé la Conv
technique ouis fait
9 et demi 3 et demi ça fait elle sait
déjà qu'elle a presque perdu ouais c'est
dur c'est pour fan qui laisse aucune
chance he franchement euh très très très
dur pour pour la je indienne qui hier
hier elle avait été redoutable dans le
match aujourd'hui c'est une toute autre
Harc qu'on
découvre la fatigue aussi du match
d'hierin ça joue aussi
[Musique]
hein ça joue aussi tout à
fait ok est-ce qu'on fait une petite
pause Kevin allez on va dans un instant
ça marche pour la fin de cette période
3+ 1 et ensuite on enchaînera avec le
Bullet c'est ça c'est ça à tout de suite
à tout de suite quel est le meilleur
moyen de suivre n'importe quel événement
échikéen Tup du monde au tournois des
candidats en passant par le speed chess
ou les title Tuesday
chess.com/events C tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base retrouvez
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contte rendus
quotidien les bios des joueurs les
règles des partartage et plus encore
vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle part
[Musique]
ailleurs
allez on est reparti Erik qui a les
blancs cette partie donc
là on te voit plus on me demande de
changer de
périphérique ah oui là j'ai buggé j'ai
une tête de une tête de fou furieux ne
regardez pas la caméra surtout s'il vous
plaît ça donne envie pourtant fou
furieux
euh comment je change ça moi
attende enlèvemi cette tête vite vite
vite vite VO on est mieux et je vais
voir si j'ai regardé mes mes réglages
c'est bonen fait j'ai mis mon USB qui
qui est un petit peu casser là et des
fois je vois que ça
bug ok voilà donc làik qui a les blanc
qui est mené 9 FO 9 et demi 3 et d' j'ai
pas j'ai pas rajouté les les petits
points là elle a joué une petite
anglaise histoire de changer un petit
peu de de crème riz parce que c'est vrai
que son anglaise contre Catarina lagno a
est plutôt fonctionné
ouais et d'ailleurs c'est une position
tout à fait intéressante qu'elle a
obtenu oui avec un jeu contre le pion D7
qui vient de partir en D5 d'ailleurs
mais le fou G2 est vraiment bien placé
dans ce genre de position même peut-être
A4 très
intéressant mangé à cause du du problème
sur le cavalier
C6 tour C1 peut-être peut être aussi
intéressant il y a eu cavalier C7 que j'
pas du tout
aussi fr C4 qui va aller prendre un pran
et tout ça ça quand même été joué assez
rapidement par par ogifan est-ce que ce
serait pas une
préparation Kevin ou est-ce que elle a
juste je sais pas elle a peut-être
trouvé elle peutre inspiré aussi parce
que c'est sympa ce qu'elle a joué avec
les noir ouais elle a inquiété de moins
mais elle a elle a le contrôle du centre
elle a un pion pour la qualité
mais je dirais que c'est peut-être un
peu lèe parce que la la colonne c'est
parce que pour voir si un serv de
qualité valable il faut voir comment les
tours vont s'activer sur les colonnes et
là j'ai l'impression que je
bientôt bientôt réussir quelque
chose c'est dire que si j'arrive avec
tour C1 B3 à ouvrir un peu la tour je
vaisre je vais être assez content non
c'est clair avage sur long terme sur le
long terme un bel avantage blan F 5 été
joué prend C4 wouh oui c
c'est et là du coup ça va être je pense
expédié parce que après tour D1 al je
sais pas laquelle même tour C1 aussi euh
je vais prendre la colonne je vais
peut-être manger un pion au passage oui
et ça va se terminer cavalier 4 tu auras
toujours 3 ouais il y a encore cavalier
des5 bon ce qui ce qui est mauvais pour
Wian c'est le
temps que Harik a quand même 2 minutes
pour convertir mais il a un peu de
boulot je trouve encore ouais mais avec
piècesangé je pense que c'est déjà le
taf il est déjà des5 donc à moitié fait
he et salut TRX même sur sur tour des un
qui des 5 F des deux ben j'ai quand même
d qu qui va arriver non c'est je vois
pas du tout les noir revenir
ici vois pas du tout ou il fa de revenir
cette partie qui une bonne nouvelle pour
Arika qui arrête un peu l'hémorragie
pour relancer un petit peu mais relancer
de loin parce qu'il y a quand même plus
6 actuellement plus 6 mais bon en fait
il faut espérer en bullette juste une
très grosse session quoi c'est ça eu il
faut espérer ça donc euh tu peux
toujours faire un petit+ 4 + 5 en
bulette donc essayer de limiter la casse
en blitz si elle commence le Bullet en à
seulement - 3 peut-être bon même là ça
reste dur là elle est elle a déjà un PER
dans la tombe hein
Arka bien sûr mais euh pour les noir B5
B3 ouais B3 et un coup à 4 est un
coup B3 d'ailleurs al je pense qu'elle
aime pas cavaill G5 5 donc elle veut
essayer de de stopper ce cavalier et B3
de suite maintenant fait il aa fou à3
ouais maintenant moi elle a protégé C4
une demiexloit ouais puis oifan va faire
durer elle a tout intérêt
à il tout intérêt à faire durer
d'ailleurs vu ce que harika faisait hier
et ben je pense qu'elle va pas se gêner
parce que harika elle a elle a jouer la
finale tour contre tourant 50 coups oui
oui elle joue le le jeu du speed chess
ouais C3 il aurait jamais dû arriver
jusque là le pion normalement ouais
alors est-ce que je peux jouer E4 voilà
et essayer de mettre le F en D4 ouais
donc h6on H6 pas manger par contre c pas
toujours ce que je voulais maintenant il
y a B4 qui peut arriver ça peut être une
belle compomense quand même avec le bon
peut-être jeamener le fou en B2 quand
même c'estàdire de faire tour
D3 ton fou B2 soit passif je peuxouer B4
déjà voilà et maintenant si joue B F
joue plus voilà et si je joue fou B2
c'est pareil
ouais mais mais si tu bouges la tour je
joue C de non en faitou pas a B4 A4
faudrait pas se faire enfumer
euh il y a un bon petit plan avec ce
petit A4 hein ouais peut-être un tour à
8 à4 là A4 direct j'avais envie bon bon
ça marche aussi hein dans ce sens là
mais là ça il y a là il a un problème
sur sur
[Musique]
jeux
malré de contre mais ça va
[Musique]
êtreuttre
jolie il y a de d'ailleurs non ah ok tu
m'enques pas alors sur ça très joli j'ai
attention j'ai pas parce ah en forme
pour
demain hier tu m'as dit que pas en forme
ouis bon
aujourd'hui on fait on fait des bêtises
on fait comme les joueuses finalement
sauau commentair ça va vite aussi VO
c'est juste perdu là ça là j'ai 5 j'ai
ça en l'air
ça fait beaucoup
trop tour B5 tour D5 là moi je pr tour
D5 échec et43 ouais dur de se réinventer
et plus du tout de jeu ma tour sera
active du coup pourra passer faire des
choses letion h et indéfendable ça va
être abandon de la part de an après elle
pourrait faire faire durer juste parce
que faire il a quand même à de attention
attention black quand
même va faire durer tant qu'elle peut
aussi le 5 si mal peut-être ro prend
j'ai éche je récupère F6 en
force C4 perd à de mais sur roi ici
ouais puis je peux prendre je peux
prendre B4 aussi pas vux
prendre4 attention per la tour quand
même ça serait
malheureux tour ici peut être un coup3
j'aime bien
aussi43
tranquillement
ça va gagner c'est long à gagner cette
position mais ça va
gagner t
F4 préfère attendre avec toutes ses
pièces et puis c'est vrai que il y a
toujours l'aspect en voulant finir je me
mets un tout petit peu mal au temps et
là il se passe un truc quoi donc
is5 un moment donné venir essayer de
sacrifier ou tout à fait tout à fait
tour D5 j'aime bien
pour
D3
salut comment tu
vas peux
même faire un peu le
ménage
[Musique]
attentionè maintenant il est dur à gérer
moi je
bouffe je tannonce
ou j'ai un peu de temps j'aime bien ce
qu' a fait t F5
contrôle pas oublier le ption
elle ve mat pas
comment faire
gaffeesalier qui va
arver pour ça faudrait qu' décale s
tour décalage décalage allez hop une V
qui fait plaisir pour en tout cas il
fait passer à 4 et demi donc Mo- 5 là il
faut encore une autre victoire pour il
faut quean se remette la tête à
l'endroit là moins bien joué celle-là
mais bon il c'est normal hein sur
l'ensemble d'un speed cha de faire
quelques parties en dedans h maintenant
elle est plutôt constante justement et
an elle a montré quand même qu'elle
était bien présente ouais c'estàd que
même dans une partie difficile elle
s'accroche et on est reparti pour qui
ait plutôt bien tourné dans l'ouverture
pour
harika on va voir si wifan se réadapte
bien C3 fou G7
génialattendance à à rejouer les mêmes
choses et l' il y avait eu à non elle
avait elle avait joué comment elle avait
joué avec
elle a fait elle avait pas fait k C3 K2
et s'était pris un fou G4 fou PR3 ah
exactement c'est
j'essaie de retrouver mais ça elle elle
a dévié mais normalement qui me dit
quelque chose donc c'est k D2 cavalier
F1 du coup les noirs des fois c'est G4
et on fait H4 avec notrealier en l'air
en H4 c'est des lignes comme ça h on
essaie de faire F4 ça me dit quelque
chose
mais B dame
B3 fait ça me paraît pas du tout dans la
dans l'ADN de la de la
variante bon maintenant j'ai plus la
poussée D5 le cavalier F3 est-ce qu'on
le met en en D2 F1 est-ce qu'on a le
temps de faire tout ça ou alors est-ce
qu'on met le cavalier A3 en C23 voilà ça
c'est plus rapide efficace et on tape
sur le point noir de la config adverse
la case
F5 case D5 aussi maisen est beaucoup
mieux tiré que la première fois je
trouve
ou estme un peu mieux là
[Musique]
g4alier pas trop peur j'aime bien com
elle joue elle refuse pas le combat
cavalier G3 cavalier F5 c'est des bonnes
compensation par rapport pice noire qui
arrive sur le
roi ça pourrait activer mon fou
attention F qui actif
il y avait sans doute cavalier D5 Stouff
pour essayer des des belles choses
ouais elle a bloqué la case mais il
fallait penser au fou
C1 ça nous a réveillé ce ce dame G5
point d'interrogation on peut le rater
en partie moi j'aurais j'aurais G5
peut-être aussi ça avait l'air pas mal
ah quand tu l'as dit j'ai bu tes paroles
alors que quand j'ai vu le gros point
d'interrogation je me suis j'ai envie
d'en profiter de cette dam en G5 ouais
cavalier G6 et H5
ouais en tout cas c'est des positions à
double tranchant et c'est ce que c'est
ce que recherche en tout cas dans ses
positions a bien raison de jouer ça et
ça anime vraiment le
jeuan F5 voulu Paran vraisemblablement
ouais et ça va être tout changé
peut-être et là il va
fairearder c'est moi qui VI me le
prendre moi jeis quand même
h S mais j'ai TR alors quand même dans
l'esprit manger deux fois bon est-ce que
je bloque ou est-ce que j'ouvre
ah prend tout ok avec eu pr F4
probablement je pense que est
obligatoire il fa ouvir le fou qume
ouais ouais oui c'est logique maintenant
c'est chaud hein les les les deux camp
sont ouverts est-ce que je joue le petit
un dame F2 pour essayer de de vraiment
faire une partie un peu soporifique ou
tour F1 dame F2 c'est peut-être la
solême
end surtout dans cette config de match
où j'ai beaucoup d'avance
ouis garder les pièces G5
avec
je
W tu vois jouer comme
ça faut quand même que je me dépêche il
y a des fous5 qui pourra arriver après a
les
noir je peux
pasuse y a plein de problèmes tacti et
F3
attention
attention une bêtise comment est-ce que
jeou elle a été trop trop
gourmande dans les f couleur toujours
que c'est le jeu sur le roi qui compte
bien après
fou5
[Musique]
logime
qui pas trop
[Musique]
trop il faut
Jer je prends ouais c'est ça mais est-ce
que c'est
[Musique]
suffisant attention que quand je prends
là je pr de échec un moment donné et
damage 5
peut-être ro F2 ben damage 4 du
coup H4 prend G2 si je fais échec roi là
et je suis je su ok ro h j'aime
beaucoupce que je peux jouer d t G8 F3
tour
G3 j'ai j'ai découverte non au pire j'ur
même du f h peutêtre ah oui c'est F H2
que jeai pas vu ça qui a l'air
intéressant bravo parce que si j'ai
changé les dames c'était ok pour moi
enfin cétait ok oui bien oui oui bah oui
oui bien
sûr pour la finale quoi c'est ça il faut
empcher jouer t G3 tour H3 aussi oui
oui donc là j'ai pas de de moyen
d'échanger ro H8 a bien
fonctionné attention wiifan qui descend
en dessous de 15 secondes
ouais bah là elle va sans doute se la
faire coller deux fois de suite hein
ouais ça pour le moral ça peut ça peut
faire plaisir he h tour G3 tour H3 aussi
ouais c'est plus facile un peu avoir
tour G3 tour H3 ouais qui arrive il y a
tout qui est intéressant là on sait que
on va se faire avoir attention quand
même parce que c'est une position on
peut cogiter avec la pression du temps
ouais pas faire trop n'importe quoi là
c'est tout de suite mat en fait
faitattend un coup non il y a roi E4
mais tour
H4 non mais ça ça et ça c'est
mal H4 c'est mant deux
coups G3 et tour H4 euh ah oui je prend
fouika elle a été ambitieuse et elle a
été payée
est 5 et demi 4 points de retard allez
joue sa petite anglaise ça fait deux
fois là c'est pas
mal ce qui a fait la c'est quand même
c'est quand même beau mener 6 points et
de revenir dans ce dans ce match donc la
pause a fait du bienan elle avait match
gagné à la pause ouais tu un petit peu
des fois tu dis pardon tu peux te
relâcher en fait quand gr
[Musique]
avantage encore faoline on pensait que
le match c'était un petit peu éteint et
elle est en train de lui redonner vie
elle joue vite elle fait elle gaffe pas
dans ses parties elle met la
pression
D3 Yume là tu tu lui proposes de mettre
une prédiction il parî sur
ah la petite côte il aime bien les
petites côtes et j'aime bien ce qu'elle
produit dans les ouvertures en fait avec
les noir je trouve que c'est très
intéressant ce qu'elle fait ces petit
ces petits trucs avec un5 l'inverse avec
les Blancs c'est souvent
euh c'est souvent modeste de mon point
de vue jou pas tranquille regarde encore
une
[Musique]
fois c'est ça tranquille et euh bon pas
génial parce que c'est pas il y a pas un
petit plus tu vois dans la partie
précédente dans l'anglaise elle va
réussi à à obtenir des petites choses
mais là à B5 c'est hyper étonnant avec
tour B1 B5 c'est le coup qu'on a pas
envie de jouer ouais cavalier prend B5
non stouf
prend B5 prend B5 prend F6 ah ouais
c'est c'est c'est niveau 1 ça bah voilà
cavalier prend B5 là
fan je sais pas ce qu'elle a mangé à la
pause
mais
pas GG là on dir qu' s'ort quelle heure
il est en Chine est-ce que tu peux nous
dire Yume quelle heure il est en
Chine puis là ouais elle est posée quoi
on sent qu'elle est un peu stoï
alors qu'elle fait
vraiment une énorme gaffe alors qu'elle
avait géré son ouverture
tranquillement pourquoi jouer
celare pour rendre le match de plus en
plus
intéressant pour nous c'est pour
nous est cont parce que je pensais qu'on
allait avoir une fin de speed à sens
unique
et nous fait mentir
faut dire queifan là l'histoire de B5 il
est 23h à Pkin B5
aprèsè ouais après tourb1 c'est assez
incompréhensible et IFAN qui a la
réputation de se coucher tôt non c'est
pas vrai du tout pas vrai du tout c'est
juste que comme elle craque on peut
trouver des explications diverses et
variées cavalier prend bon c'est un pion
plus mais c'est le pion qui
un petit pion qui est bloqué après d à 7
il faut quand même aller chercher ce
pion
hein peut-être pas le meilleur coup tour
des8 dame C2 dame C8 peut-être ah j'ai
envie de tenter hein j'ai envie de
tenter il faut tenter je pense que
c'était pas bien la dame défendait bien
là elle a tout raté en fait parce que
non mais d ça gagne dame C2 dame B2
c'est indéfendable bah ça a l'air chaud
hein ok F5 faut trouver un autre ouais
trouvé F5 parce que dame B2 l'inquétait
trop dame C8 ah oui pr 6 prend à je fais
échec échec voilà et bon là je vais mat
avec
H4 là elle joue plus du tout il fan
là il faut se rveiller
là la pause bien mais c'est c'est aussi
parce quean joue plus du tout là ouais
gros coup de barre avec le plus 6 et
attention il y a la période du Bullet
qui arrive derrière il y aura sans doute
au moins une partie derrière ce oui
après enc il y aura une partie par
qu'elle va résister un petit chouya là
H4
ok h H5 son les Noirs menacent rien ils
ont défendu 6 bien H4 redenez ça on est
tranquille H4 on ramène du monde à la
fête et H5 ferme le réseau comme nous
mon bah oui t prend à deux c'est comme
tout à l'heure donc en fait les Noirs ne
menacent rien donc tu as le temps en
fait de faire sur de choses F7 peut-être
prend à 6 là c'est c'est quasiment
abandon hein bah je pense c'est même
abandon
quasiment
abandon H5 je vouis faire
ok intéress bien très
intéressant la
dame la dame en F8 aussi après selon ce
qui est joué
[Musique]
ou dis pas mal je pense c'est perd per
Touré J dame à 8 belle belle petite
défense ouais je viens ici D F dame G8
va être obligé et maintenant comment je
termine j'ai H5 intéressant qume souign
prend7
ouais mais du coup j'avis tour d dans
celll est-ce que je peux jouer tour D6
là dans cette position pour tenir tour
D6 pour essayer de faire une petite
finale tour B6 pas mal hein parce que
j'ai des idées de tour B1 dame a 8 sur
un malentendu ah ah pas maintenant parce
qu' le pion à G7 mais ça peut
marcher alors j'ai plus de coupou je
sais pas quoi jouer tour
C6 il y a H5 c'est encore tout temps de
menace quoi prendre pr G7 damage
4me pour que il n'y ait plus qu'une
partie derrière je pense qu'elle a envie
que ça se finisse pas mal cette histoire
de dame F6 peut-être la finale de tour
c'est la seule qui peut être légèrement
critique H5 non h h so pas la suite
horrible pas la
suite
me c'est léger
mais décision ah ou j'auris jamais fa
fin je va éliminer les pion je pense que
c'est nul cette position sur un bon jeu
noir
G4
ouais pas facile du tout hein va y avoir
de la cible il y a le pion F2 en cible
je pense que c'est nul tu pens que tu
mets ton2 tu te caches j'ai ouais j'ai
pas trop besoin tu vois Souf parce que
là je peux rester même avec le RO en E5
CIT tranquille quoi oua c'est quand même
pas mal ah si tu veux ouais ouais c'est
c'est peut-être encore mieux mais bon
enfin j'ai plus d'inquiétude peut-être
E5 avec les noirs E5 et tour
elle a mis la tour en la p en A7 en plus
donc il y a plus de cash après E5
voilà normalement tu sais on essaie de
laisser le P à de toute façon ça change
rien complètement craqué c'est dommage
pour elle parce que
[Musique]
incroyable plus elle perd du temps enfin
c'est la totale quoi l'occasion ratée ou
ou on avait complètement condamné depuis
un bon moment petit
drame bon ça va faire nul réussir
à est nul
aïe c'est quand même un
bel de de retard
ouais elle a failli avoir TR points mais
c TR points tu g la dernière ça fait de
tu P Ain 2 bien sûr Mo 2 céit
complètement jouable tu me diras là ça
reste encore à peu près jouable mais bon
là il faut qu' gagne si gagne ça c'est
la dernière partie du 3elle gagne là euh
elle est encore vivante si elle perd je
pense que c'est très très très dur même
si elle gagne pas et joue toujours son
petit
système7 contre fou E7 mais contre h G5
c'est vraiment pas
obligatoire que le jeu est plus au
centre en réaction au jeu et le roi des
Noirs qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici tuux tu
ve manger ou pasement
tuardertal qui fait une belle apparition
dit un peu déçu apparemment de ma tenue
pas de doudoune mais c'est je suis un
peu déçu aussi hein bon ben je ser un
effort la prochaine fois après si tu la
M tu prends les photos je pense
queal ser cont il va tout de suite être
content petit rock prise
ok bon c'est une partie beaucoup plus
standard ouaisme sur quand même h isolé
mais compensation avec des bonnes pièces
côté blanc bon est-ce que je joue
cavalier C3 simple ouais ça il a
peut-être prise et fou prend5 la finale
non il a fou de cou opposé donc kc3
c'est bien
ok F 6 qu' on joue dame
2 position stable pour les blancs
ouais même alors faire attention comme
vous avez là dame B3 a été joué J je
n'aime pas mais ça a l'air assez logique
quand Mme dame
B3 tu B3 ici on peut imaginer tour
derrière et même du Caval 4 peut-être un
jour venir sur ces case là point de
surrogation c'est dur en tout cas hein
oui oui bon après la jauge tu sais un pe
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr je
veux dire c'est que les coups les coups
blancs sont vraiment standard
ne vous siiez pas
justement c'est plutôt propre on a
plutôt à chaque coup il y a un truc
mais mais
euhoui al là là là il se prenent du du
rouge DIF là là franchement on regarde
les quatre derniers
coups blanc noir là pour le coup il y a
peut-être un problèmeouf il y a qu'
prendre5 pour les blancs ouais et
c'est ça et
sur forcer remettre mes pion
correctement il aura la fourchette en D
à la
[Musique]
fin pour changer la structure de
pion
c'est histoire de changement de
structure de pion c'est terrible elle a
trouvé je pense mais après ouais elle le
fait après maintenant il y a plus le
truc en C6 mais ça va quand même être
pénible ça se
sent 5 des fois les joueurs voi les
lignes mais juste après ais grand
classique une bonne rage là avant il y
avait des problème en
C6 attention le F6 quand même pas il
était pas safe safe est-ce qu'on pouvait
jouer un KG6 quelque chose comme
ça
possible intéressant en tout cas de
d'essayer produire quelque chose avec le
le F6 en vis-àis ouais elle se
chauffean peut-être aussi pour le Bullet
elle est beaucoup plus
rapide
[Musique]
attention
m je peux quand même faire
ça pour de
poinrogation du coup tu jou quoi à la
place c'était pas ça du
coup je sais pas d prend de4 alors j'ai
mangé un
pion dame F4 ici va être joué
probablement cavalier prend
F4 et j'ai mangé mon petit pion j'ai mon
petit pion j'ai en majorité de ce
côté-là je pièce que je peux changer
aussi
ici l'impression que que areka elle est
quand même bien parti encore pour gagner
celle-là c'est vraiment dommage qu'elle
n'it pas gagné la partie précédente
parce qu'elle a vraiment plus se rap
fortement de fan dans ce match B4 fa
prend B4 et ici il faut prendre B5 deux
pièces pour la tour c'est c'est écras un
clur de fond en plus qui tape sur B2 je
pense que ça va être gagné facile le
temps est arrivé à zé donc c'est la
dernière partie du set avant le Bullet
G3 a été joué on peut jouer cavalier D5
cavalier convertir oui non là ça va
convertir là ça va convertir quand même
de pièces pour la tour avecès 20
secondes tu sais les positions toujours
un petit peu bizarres pourquoi elle elle
rend le
matériel je rate quelque chose ou non
non B enfin ça doit être gagnant mais
c'est en fait que j'ai raté non en fait
moi
je
prendend ça va pas donc c'est pour ça
que la jugé difficile sans doute ouais
oui oui je suis d'accord pour TR jouable
ici F TR joubl j'ai F des de
aussi toujours pire cas prend j la au P
des cas voilà il faudra pe-êre le jouer
d'ailleurs he joue tour3
j'essaie parce que même cette position
bon en fait c'est c'est F même couleur
siis tu manges ici et que je mange ta
pièce et fou des cas deux points
d'interrogation donc là je fais GF sans
doute ouais à la fin je récupère un
récupère les deux et là je peux jouer la
nulle dans la finale on pe la nul ou
alors f des deux c'était la même sauf
que le fou était pas prise non
ouais exact F5
de du de gagner position après techque
15 secondes c'est vraiment technique
identique au
Bullet
jouer aprs c'est de même couleur quand
même même
couleur bien joué comment je passe
maintenant il faut t tris tours des de
quelque chose comme ça t prend un ch
complètement jouable
elle s'est fait arnaquer
par des4 3 C3 ça fait du bien là pour
les blancs ouais mais sont partis donc
pe-être ça fait nul Etik qui qui a deux
parties
d'affil fa nul elle peut gagner elle
aurait pu revenir à deux points
ok ouais mais écoutez on a moin 5 he du
coup dans le score moins 4
pardon ant le Bullet et dans le Bullet
il y a pas de pause hein Souf non non il
y a pas de pause hein c'est une
demi-heure une demi-heure
straight et euh c'est bon ce que nous
met neertal il est toujours aussi
pertinent dans ses remarques il manque
comme pour le football avec l'expected
goal la statistique de l'expected Win ça
c'est bon
ça très très bon nandertal fidèle à
toi-même c'est là vous avez vous avez
les prédictions en direct de partcom et
bon là on va on va plancher prédiction
globale prédiction globale sur la sur la
partie en cours serait bon hein d'avoir
cette stat là ouais ouais ouais c'est
clair c'est clair après là c'est pas
c'est pas possible je pense pour
l'instant techniquement parlant bah ça
va augmenter hein plus plus de de
possibilités h est-ce que c'est la
dernière pause avant oui on va faer une
petite pause de 5 minutes on vous
retrouve d'ici euh bah 5 minutes pour
euh dénouement et puis pour demi-heure
de Bullet le Bullet une plus c'est assez
spectaculaire donc je vous invite à
rester parmi nous pour cette dernière
prion une minute plus une seconde par
cou est-ce que Harik va réussir
à à revenir au score sur
IFAN donc réponse dans un instant tout
de
suite vous voulez streamer des échecs
comme vos créateurs préférés tels que
bstream Naka ou les surbotz let's go on
le programme de Community streamer de
tess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte àess.com et profitez de la
visibilité offerte par notre plateforme
de jeu il vous suffit de relier votre
compte à
chess.com/settings/connecting-econs
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer vous
bénéficierez d'une expérience sans
publicité sur Chess.com et apparaîtrez
dans notre liste de streamers en direct
votre profil Chess.com affichera votre
stream twitch qui sera aussi mis en
avant durant vos parties enfin utilisez
la commande community streamer dans le
chat et faites grossir votre audience
sans plus
[Musique]
attendre
saz-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vos analyses avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur les chiquers
vous pouvez choisir parmi une multitude
de notations de coup d'animation
d'emmoticone et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs les
émoticones et les mojis disparaîtront au
bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coup et les animations
spéciales restent sur les chiquers
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient effacé pour
se faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton tout effacé
essayez-les tous et amusez-vous bien sur
[Musique]
Chess.com
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin pour
cette al Kevin il est pas là si il est
là ça je peux pas voir en direct comme
il y a le délai de 20 secondes
moi je te moi je te vois et euh et du
coup un qui elle est blanc et elle est M
de 4 points dans ces bullettes donc il
va falloir il va falloir vraiment faire
la machine et tout gagner elle a 30
minutes pour en ouais en une demi-heure
on fait combien de bullettes Stouff en 1
plus 1 faire 8 à 10 à peu près
ouais tu vois en fait parce que c'est
c'est c'est euh cadence 5 + 1 euh 3 + 1
et une+ une avec les les temps qui sont
imp partis c'est au final un peu pour
faire le même nombre de par Ch VO là il
y a eu a une parties enfin le score
c'est 5 + 3 8 dans le 5 + 1 bien sûr euh
9 dans le 3 + 1 donc je 8 à 10 parties
on est juste quoi ou voilà je pense que
ouais 8 9 10 max
pend un peu de comment ça ça va évoluer
mais bon un plus 4 sais tu commences mal
bon bah
écoute ça peut ça peut tourner et si
vraiment arrive à mettre la pression a
temp et à produire de belles choses et
ben pour moi c'est pas impossible
qu'elle revienne encore au soir même si
ça reste bien sûr difficile dans cette
dans ce match
hein point c'est elle vient de revenir
pour la première fois et puis on on l'a
vu plus rapide pendant tout le long du
match donc euh
ouais elle peut jouer là-dessus on
espère pour elle en tout cas ouais en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on espère
c'est ça T4 a été joué après des fois
elle peineent un petit peu à
à à à convertir hein parce qu'elle eu
bah là on a vu les deux dernières
parties qu'elle a joué elle avait
l'avantage dans les deux et et au
finalan quand joue pas très bien elle
résiste hein évidemment ouais elle
résiste attention avec le piège
peut-être E5 est-ce que c'est un piège
véritable il a eu foupr pas sûr c'est
pas sûr
peut-être mais après fprend
maintenant il a plus
5me reste une
[Musique]
ide
attention calier qui reste en prise
faudra faire
attention
J
ok fa un peu mal quand
même peux jouer quand même sur le P à 2
si je mangeais F7 peut-être il attaqu
deux pièces tu avais du mal à défendre
tranquille incroyable j'aime bien Atta
D6 peut-être juste tour D8 on défend
toutes nos faiblesses en plus c'est
facile à jouer K3 peut-être pour
cavalier prend les tour ici et je
pensais jouer tour a mais il a A4 et
après on peut pas attaquer B c'est ça je
pense c'est perdu cette partie il y a un
pion de plus de pion passé lié euh si il
y a pas de problème de technique ça doit
re gagner facilement 5 peut-être même à
5 ouais a 5 j'aime bien a 5 doit gagner
il y a aussi tout rchec3 qui ah voilà
attention elle peine un peu chaque fois
on revient aussi tour là qui est pas mal
mais j'aime pas donner mon pion B
quandme ouais elle se complique encore
peut-être la tâche attention à tour B4
et ramasse le pion a je fa tour a quand
même quand même deux pions passés
protégés cétait fort hein
elle a raté l'ch il prendre les 5 je
crois on va voir la même
finale c'est dur ce genre de
position qu'est-ce qu'elle nous fait
qu'est-ce qu'elle nous fa ouais a a a a
a a Aï la technique c'est pas son point
fort l'impression ka ah dans dans le
mononey Time quoi ro G7 ro G7 pass se
faire enfiler par derrière là on fait ro
G7 H7 et maintenant comment je passe
peutêtre fait roag qume je
pense non non non ça gagne pas cette
position non non c'est sûr que non c'est
les pions G H il faut avoir le pion F
pour enlever le le roi donc là tu sais
ouis
j'attends quand tu montes il faut avoir
un pion pour enlever ton BO de ha il est
trop bien placé là là elle va faire nul
ça fait trois fois d'affilé
franchement c'est des escroocs ouais non
mais est-ce qu'elle est tellement
gagnante dans toutes les parties elle
arrive pas à confirmer tu imagines si là
on lui met plus tr mais
après c'est quand même dur avec la
pression du temps de gagner les
positions gagnantes je dis pas que je je
suis d'accord mais c'est vrai que dans
la pratique tu as deux pions passés
protégés tu vas tu vas garder tes pions
euh
mais comme tu
dis en
fait la la problématique c'est que ça
lui arrive trop souvent oui c'est ça ça
TR a des des finales archigagnantes
alors bon je dis pas en plus mais
celle-là avec AB bonah tu dois te
débrouiller pour tu vois on avait dit A5
faut garder la tour active et souvent
elle fait les mauvais choix de prise de
pion alors c'est très facile en tant
commentateur de dire ça mais oui nous on
pas 3 He d'éche dans la gueule on n pas
joué hier non plus c'est un peu
différent jeu
mais techniquement C2 c'est un coup ou
ça va être un coup en plus on voit
franchement
qui fatigue vachement c parti elle fait
pas mal de de bêtises elle s'accroche
mais c'est pas aussi clean que c'était
en début de match non clairement pas
après il est tard chez eux aussi bien
sûr donc F F6 cétait la question dame D2
là je peux pas faire un truc dame G4
c'est juste dame H6 dame G4 H6 6 c'est
horrible damage 6 aussi 6 mais bon
damage 6 l'air très fort damage 6 ah oui
pas V c'est énorme la défense de folie
voyez H2 j'aurais roi H1 ah non voilà
exactement ouais c'est roi F1 ouais
c'est pas sûr damage 6 plus
[Musique]
clean t D1 damage 6 ouais bon c'est plus
vraisemblablement 5 pris C6 exact et
ouifan elle est quand même pas très bien
déjà pour démarrer
et
maintenant d
[Musique]
G67 et bon partie avec avantage
pour çair en finale de tour est-ce que
tu préd finale de tour et match
nul la config idéale pour le faire il
faut qu'elle arrive à changer les dames
quoi j'espère qu'on aura la finale de de
tour mais bon c'est ça m'a l'air assez
quand même ouf de de what euh la souris
ah non pardon c'est pas la souris du
tout c'esti pas mal pas mal j'ai CR
qu'elle avait qu'elle avait RIP pend une
petite seconde en fait c'est malin ce
qu'elle a fait t
7 et elle trouve du jeu elle trouve des
trucs et ça ça peut faire douter àik qui
va peut-être vouloir échanger ent AC les
histoires de tour6 oh là prend tour G6
mais en plus là maintenant ça perd enfin
c'est hyper chaud quoi ouais bon il a g
nul hein tu as 4 points
[Musique]
d'avance qu points
d'avanceou échec d'abord tu prends H5
sur échec tu vas manger C5
ouais mais le problème c'est le pion d
quoi moi ça me fait vachement peur le
pion d après il y a encore la nul quand
même que tu peux faire he il faut que je
joue comment pour gagner euh je pense ça
va prendre nul ou alors je joue un petit
Dame des deux malin et à CH pris nul
elle a pris
nul des de pour envoyer le pion h mais
bon on peut comprendre que dans la
config avec les points d'avance et 20
minutes qui nous
reste imagine que ça fait quatre parties
d'filé qui était complement gagnante et
que là elle aurait pu
euh elle aurait pu revenir au score hein
c'est not combien bullettes il y a eu
que deux bullettes Souf il y a eu euh il
y a eu deux nuls ouais de nul mais les
deux parties de 3+ 1
euh été gagnant nous reste à peu près
six parties et il y a plus 4 quoi autant
dire que oui mais tu vois un moment elle
avait gagné les quatre parties ah oui
oui avait joué alors les quatre étaient
complètement gagnantesin gag les qu
qureur été un peu exagéré parce qu'il y
a souvent des retournements on l' vu
mais mais tu as raison al ou TR relan
matê il y a une partie où c'était mat
quasiment àar l'autre c'était la finale
de tour avec un plus on a et b passé
aprs je plus toutes les parties mais
c'était il me sembleéit quand même assez
surtoutan quand de position elle elle
convertit quoi ah tu donnes les position
à fait 4 bien sûr et donc tu vois c'est
c'était possible encore une fois
maintenant il a malheureusement trop
d'occasion
raté qui on sent un peu la fatigue tu
vois qui qui en fait tellement sous
pression qu'elle Ess de simplifier les
choses et au final elle se complique
toute la vie alors oui est pareil on est
mieux on a pas envie de se faire
arnaquerouff et en fait des fois on
déjoue on déjoue et oui c'est encore mal
hein cavalier
C3 le pion C5 il va presque tomber un
Stouff
ouais et des deux très bien
aussi prend il a peut-être du4 qui peut
arriver un jour et c'est
vraiment qu'est-ce que tu fais
maintenant FD2 je trouvais que c'était
un coup magnifique de la part
pas le problème
poséam lesames
justez
prise changer des pièceson estce qu'on
va aller jouer la
[Musique]
finard M la
attention dame d la FA bonne nouvelle
ouais c'est ça la préféré d'ailleurs
maintenant fait plus à
voirour Dame à
2 ah oui tour ça tout simplement7 et
c'est fini je prends A7 je prends F7
allez prends A7
etabandon ok c gagné propre plus 3
seulement fan c'est l'ombre d'elle même
quand même depuis elle joue elle joue
pas bien depuis euh depuis elle est
dominé dans toutes les parties et R nous
sort une scandinave avec Dame des6 ok
donc en en blitz ça passe tout à fait
même en LAN la dame D6 c'est c'est quand
même la la plus créa et la plus sympa
maintenant
ou une des plus
sympasess fou F4 ah je pis c'est Dame B4
quand on joue non ah
non là je ne sais pas attention hein fou
C4 c'est Dame 4 ok cavalier F3 rigolo
faut jouer des coups ouais moi je C4
juste
ouais il fou a fou4 c'est vraiment
bizarre elle a bloqué le fou C8 oua
c'est pour ça qu'elle a eu le droit à
une mauvaise note ouais F peut-être et
sortir le fou avant de faire normalement
on aime bien dans ces structures là on
dit que dans les structures de de Carau
scandinav et cetera on aime bien avoir
le fou C8 sortie dans cette structure
E66 là ça va pas être facile allez des
coup
là C5
ça sent C4 D5 ça sent le le petit D5
arrivé attention c'est pas bien
développé côté D5 a été Mo je posé untit
peu au hasard ce petit D5 avec Dame
[Musique]
2 mauvaise nouvelle c'est d'autes ligne
D6 mais2 c'est quoi parce que fou 7 fou
D6 he
aïe AE a il va falloir jouer roi des h
là je crois et roi des h j'aV pas trop
envie de le faire petit rock
jouer une belle poubelle est-ce que je
joue fou
c7tenant
abandon allez je joue fou prend des6 dam
prend tour je vise
mon bon le plus 4 il est en train
d'enterrer oui non c'est terminé il
reste on
4 il faut faire 4-0 il faut faire 4-0
4-0 tu les as 4-0 tu arrives au
départage hein en 4 départag il aura
quatre parties
complmentire ok B on y est pas encore
hein c'est c'est des
allersretour mais mais bon on est loin
mais franchement je pense qu'il y avait
moyen de de rattraper un peu tout ça vu
le le gros coup de mou IFAN dans ce
match ouais ça va lui faire du bien
cette victoire IFAN parce qu'elle devait
sentir elle-même que ça allait pas trop
ouais là ce A4 est bien étonnant aussi
parce qu'après B4 on se demande comment
on va garder A4 toute la partie pas B55
et ce petit pion a l'air le pion A4 A3
et k C3 pour bien mettre k C3 C4
IFAN
là qu'elle est fatiguée qu'elle a envie
que que le match se termine j'ai
l'impression ouais ouais ou oui comme
s'il a déjà gagné alors attends est-ce
que je peux croquer EU5 non c'est une
mauvaise
idée
Chezelle mais est vraiment fatigué c'est
vraiment ça stouf oui et la partie
d'avant euh C scandinave ça lui fait du
bien quand même parce que sinon il y
avait un
risque parce qu'elle y est clairement
plus à part résister dans la finale dans
les finales elle ne fait plus
grand-chose elle ne produit plus comme
en début de match ouais après c'est
quand même plus dur de produire en
bulette hein pour sty c'est quandême un
style qui estth très positionnel et en
c'est difficile de de prendre des cases
tout ça mais on a vu quand même que par
rapport à ces standards c'était oui bien
sûr c'est bizarre quand même bizarre il
y a des
décisions tu sais le B5 face à la Tour
B1 c'est des décisions bon normalement
on peut pas faire puis là qui C4 Etik
qui retrouve un petit peu voyant je
pense qu'elle le sent hein que son
adversaire n'y est plus elle a eu plein
d'occasions comme tu nous l'as expliqué
dans les finales et du coup ben je
commence à a jouer simple et vite en
plus
ouais alors comment on joue contre cette
attaque là c'est pas évident de se
prendre l'attaque là 3 2 pour l'instant
il y a pas F3 et dès que le cavalier F6
part on pourra jouer fou E4
peut-être fou C3 donc elle défend ici
puis elle se permet en plus un jour
peut-être de faire à 5 tempo voilà c'est
fait 4 et tr Hin aussi peut être une
idée pour euh3 ou G43 aussi alors G4 pas
mal de cas 2 G4 le problème c'est F3
peut-être moi j'aime bien F3 j'aime bien
F3 pour passer la tour et défendre un
peu comme ça quoi attention pion D5
quand même peut-être qu'il peut être
pris ah ouais ah c l'idée coup dam 5 là
ça fait un tout petit peu un petit Mo je
Revens avec G4 c'est plus
pare FG est-ce que FG c'est pas mal non
sououff av FG je crois que c'était
vraiment cool FG Cali 3 bah ouais ça
faisit des choses mais bon là là c'est
en train de friller ouais ça a tourné
déjà ça a tourné F3 est imparable G4
dame prend G4 et dame bouge fou H4 dame
G6 ça va être ça va être jouer cavalier
F5 le cavalier qui s'active complètement
c le cavalier qui pouvait venir en E3
tour G8 c'est bien aussi hein il A4
aussi qui arrive c'est le mode défense
c'est c'est très dur est-ce qu'il y a
pas un machin qui peut arriver un jour
un presque d' machin oui t G6 moi je m
elle va pas se prendre la tête là tour
B8 peut arriver tour B7 peut-être
ou tour
G7 tour G6 c'est bien aussi attention
avec tour à6 le tout pour le T à5
attention il y a plus de temps plus de
temps faut jouer
viteage damage 2amage 1 tomb
[Musique]
oui là c'est la défaite on peut presque
l'annoncer stou ouais c'est terminé 5
points de retard avec 13 minutes de
temps c quasiment impossible tu fais
environ euh euh je pense une partie
toutes les 4 5 minutes donc il reste
environ tris à qure parties 5 points de
retard
euh P même si euh même si ou fan perer
trois quatre partffilé ça dans le Bullet
c'est très très aléatoire on le voit
hein franchement ouais il y a des gros
retournements très rapidement
[Musique]
e la question en tout cas
avec marche
pas très
problé son très ouver et les noir dis
plus blan gros
av Cali F6 Bou
[Musique]
calier moralement c'est dur
aussi demand dans la scandin c'est quoi
l'idée de mett la dame en6 plôt
que5 on pourit dire que quand est on pas
avec cavalier c le développement en fait
est différent Yume complètement
différent de de la scandinave classique
plus de pression en rle générale sur le
pion
D4 mais vraiment c'est des schémas de
jeu différents c'est difficile à
expliquer comme ça
oralement en tout cas là
c'est je pense que wiifan elle est
soulagée et maintenant elle elle fait
une bonne partie
elle a eu elle a eu un gros coup de mou
hein elle a fait peut-être 4 5 6 7 non
peêre 6 je pense partie vraiment très
bizarre et là maintenant elle se remet à
à très bien joué et c'est passé quand
même ouais bonà ça va là ça va gagner il
y avait quand même beaucoup d'avance et
puisik n'a pas réussi à s les
opportunité au moment où où elle cétait
présente on peut faire tourner longtemps
ouis c'est si c'est possible tour
6 F3 tranquille il a pas de problème H4
un jour ouais fou C1 j'aime bien dame
dame3 tranquille dame
C2 puis elle peut faire durer hein comme
on le sait il n reste 10 minutes mais je
pense qu' pr même pas durer s'en fout
match est gagné oui c'est ça dame là
dame là elle joue aux échac
elle joueéch G3 ro G2
peut-être tranquillement
C6 va partir en B5 pass se pu en l'air
en B5 pour l'instant
je garde les PR B5 c'est très bien je
préfère garder mon P
D4 bien G3 tranquille le
petit le petit roi
G2 partir
AC c'est
impossiblefendre pour C6
bien
comment pas
[Musique]
facile
plus
ça
comm
attention conversion est aussi
compliqué très
[Musique]
vite plus
temp pas
deber
74 F5 c'est
terminé il faut on VO
pas
gagné gag finalement c'est marrant ça va
faire nul probblement est-ce que ça joue
alors nul accord
mutuel c'est
beau allez 14 à ce match salut sur
Youtube hello à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent et vous sentez 14 à 9 il
reste 8 minutes même si c'est du 1 plus
1 il n'y aura pas le temps matériel pour
revenir pour harika ouais ça va être
trop difficile
là qui a été quand même globalement
dominé mais à un moment oùifan a eu un
gros passage à vide et elle n'a pas
converti plusieurs positions gagnantes
et ça aurait pu la ramener dans le match
complètement elle avait le occasion a
pas saisi il y a eu je crois quatre
parties affiné qui étai qui étit
complètement gagnante
pour des finales qui éta assez
simple et du coup bon de base était
quand même pas bien elle était quand
même mené en en 5+ 1 mené en 3+ 1 aussi
mais il aurait pu un moment donné
peut-êtreevenenir après peut-être que
serait pas passé comme ça s'il avait
enfîné les
peut-êtrean ait quand même réagi
différemment on sait pas trop hein
mais mais quand mêmeomber 8 A3 B4
logique on va essayer de prendre un peu
l'espace de ce côtél F4 réaction normale
enc l'attaque comme d'habitude on a
pris5 et sen fout G2 il a
F3 G2 ou dame 2 et le roi qui va se
balader mais tourchin je crois que ça a
l'air d'aller sur je mettre un cavalier
en G5 mais bon il y aura cavalier4 ouais
il faut que j'arrive à à bloquer un peu
tout
ça ou
alors moiême faire4 avec les noir tu sa
dans ces position
là trs bien inéress
clair j'
bien tour
G8
doit aller vite parce qu'elle est
dominée dans cette partie autant par
une je pensais que peutre pouser les
là-bas et au final c'est la course allez
on pousse on pousse on pousse pousse
pousse et on réagit au centre onit pas
grandchose là
ouais la n'aime pas du tout 7 c'est pas
pas sexy la finale je pense qu'elle a
pas vu d'un prend H7 x pion de moins bah
de toute façon là elle joue très très
vite pour mettre la pression à IFAN elle
sait qu'elle est gênée mais il y a le
pion de plus
elles sont obligé de jouer de manière
très spontanée ouais tour F2 tour
E2 il y a le qui arrive ça a l'air ça
l'air quand même ass voà on va faire
corp avec nos pions c'est ça il y a deux
pions ici mais les pions noirs sont plus
avancés il y a que roi ici en plus
ça va aller t D2 là pour mettre le roi
sur la première c'était sympa tour D2
ouais et tour B2 ça va être un G noir le
RO noir est trop est trop gêné il y a
des réseau de mat en plus contrairement
àen F3 c'est bien aussi
ouais on va aller chercher il y aura F2
tour1 terminé
terminado allez tour G1 et jouer jouer
finame et roi des de c'est le je 4
minutes et on est à
159ou ça la déroulé
là la déroul il reste 4 minutes alors la
dernière partie peut-être ou
l'avantdernière on voir
qute
maintenant
[Musique]
F3 comment qu'on va jouer ici A4 ok
cavalier2 cavalier G3 donc on va jouer
C3 probablement per Tiger tu as pas joué
ça tout fement une per Tiger
h je la même sur4 quand j'étais petit
d'accord
euh sinon non je crois pas que j'ai j
position donc là c'est le schéma
autrichien de balancer ses trois pions
he dans ces dans C ouais moi
généralement j'aime pas trop poser le
pion F pourtant je suis un genre qui
aime bien attaquer mais ouais ça tirait
bien pourtant et même le schéma avec
Glen noir c'est intéressantenir j'aime
pas du tout
j'aime pas du tout donner le centre
comme ça j'aime bien quand même dans tu
sais même dans dans la d'or contrôler un
minimum 5 je suis pas fan de donner tout
mon centre j'arrive pas je peux pas
faire fou3 là fait dame B1 ou dame C2
pour jouer contre t cavalier préféis
faire F3 garder mon fou3 d'abord ouais
ouais parce que maintenant il est pas il
a disparu es sont fatigué les les jeunes
femmes bon et puis
il y a aussi la déception pour côté har
la satisfaction
côtéan il estard il est tard mais elle
est contente mais il estard chez
il est aussi
en 4 diff la France je sa pas s ok je
pense çaêtre plus tard que chez
nous qu'il est il est
21h 21h en et minuit en Chine comme ça
penseenlève attention faut défendre sur
les
menacour c'est c'est bien pour les
blans
g5e AR
calierès
bien cavalier F6 ser vraiment
génial W regardais mais
je pe-êre much to 21 en Inde ouais 21 en
Inde voà fou aussi c'estelleenvoie tout
mais il y a rien du tout d pr je prends
ici elle a rendu la tour qui était
peut-être pas le nécessaire comment joue
est-ce qu'on joue cavalier F4 est-ce
qu'on joue dam H4 bon elle s'amuse hein
elle s'amuse he c'est qu'elle a
gagné truc marrant elle le fait C
4 j'ai ça
attention
mais sur
blan les de pions les de pions envoy le
petit échec qui fait du bien quand
mêmeit du bien ça viens te replacer et
si tu peux le pion sur D5
B3 F4 c'était un peu
bizarre en même temps fallit tenir là
ouais
prend
de ça perdu autant et il reste une
dernière partie qui a
commencé la dernière partie du
match dernière partie du
match est-ce que vair à 5
5 5 points de retard il reste 40
secondes 20 secondes maintenant
ça va
être être perdu dame
C2 cal2 ok
c'est5 du classique dans cette
varianteque ce cavalier qui a l'air
d'être un petit peu en jeu avec les
noirs bon5 pour le sauver voilà ça c'est
thématique c'est assez facile à jouer
avec les Noirs
h
paradoxalement B4 prise prise cou D7
ouis parce que la tour F pour arriver
vite en
C8 attention à la tour B4 un peu
bizarre G4 cavalier E5 pour justement
essayer de profiter de cas les cases je
peux je peux rebondir et on est à zéro
sur le temps réglementaire donc c'est
bien la dernière partie du match on peut
déjà annoncer la la grande gagnante du
championnat speed
2024 d'ailleurs Kin je saais pas sa que
avait déjà battu l'an en 2019 en
demiinale
du du
SPE il avait perdu la
finale pas four je
vu devoir oui
BLAMON robinside et du coup je me suis
laissé un peu avoir avec mais moi je
savais pas je l'ai vu hier je CIS que
international qui l'a mis sur
sur un des réseaux j'ai vu un truc et
apparemment elle arrive en finale en
2019ik et elle a pas gagné la finale
elle a perdu par contre je sais plus
fin prend une une belle petite fessée
pour finir parce qu'on voit
queactive dans tous les sens tour C3
tour en C8 peut-être elle fait une jolie
dernière partie pour fêter ça pour le
moment parce qu'on sait que ça
PE4
terminado jou vite et
propre D 2 tourb
de MO j'aais bien même d
22 pour faire peur
changer un peu mais ça va perdu d roir
on échange les dames et maintenant pe
plus la
perdre les prend il faut changer les
pièces
avec mignon
ouais là elle fait le travail tout
doucement
ou suffira
pas
trucche t là c'est
juste les petits
pions tout est bon c'est toujours long
de gagner une partie vous voyez hein
même malgré l'avantage faut
s'employer H5 H4
peut-être je préfère jouer avec G5 il y
a tour des de si la M cavalier prend
h et là on va peut-être avoir tour tour
G4 ou tour
H4 TR marrant parce que ça devient une
galère à gagner ouis alorsen fait tu as
gagné le match quoi juste allez tu
reprends fait nul tu veux gagner
hein là tu vois un peu les championnes
même si même si c'est tu as gagné le
match déjà tu veux finir en
beauté tu veux finir en beauté
travaille adversaire attention de pas
tomber pour fan parce qu'on sait
que c'est marrant le roi est pris dans
une sorte de boîte et pour en sortir
c'est compliquer h et là elle va tomber
ah elle tombe incroyable elle perd
autant mais bon toute façon le match
était était plié quand Mme le son petit
11e point elle aura fini il aura quand
même fini à moin 4 et il y a quand même
je pense quelques regretsin je pense oui
clairement clairement stouf on les
ressent les les regrets
côté parce que bah comme dans cette
partie elle était un peu plus rapide
mais elle a gafé elle a pas pu jouer en
confiance rapidement plus des
conversions qui n'ont pas été réalisées
ça fait quand même
beaucoup pour elle parce qu'elle est
elle est capable de le faire c'est ça
elle a été mené elle a été menée en 5 +
1 mais en 3+ 1 elle avait quand même
réussi au final bon elle était menée
aussi mais les deux dernières parties 3+
1 elle était complètement gagnante elle
a pas gagné et quand elle a commencé le
Bullet elle a commencé par deux matchs
nuls qui devait normalement être
gagnante pour elle et en fait elle a
quatre parties d'affilé où elle a fait
nul où elle aurait dû gagner mais c
avantages vraiment décisif et euh et au
finalahement 4 points donc voilà mais
c'est vrai quand même dans le match elle
a été dominée je pense que et triomp
modeste pour Yan il me semble pas
qu'elle soit levée qu'elle ait qu'elle
ait levé les bras non non non elle é un
petit sourire un petit sourire ouais
ouais ouais donc là je pense que
maintenant son parti en interview avec
chesscom international
super et voilà donc je peux remettre un
petit peu si vous voulez avant de
terminer le braquet final avec je sa pas
sil était mis à jour non je c mis à jour
je sais pas si jour si c'est à jour
c'est à jour ils sont trompés sur le
score juste ils onté les scores ils ont
a gagné 15 11 mais c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai c'est
an qui a gagné 151 je vous l'assure je
vous le
promets doncable finale avec du coup la
finale qui vient de se terminer et voilà
merci en tout cas à tous d'avoir avoir
suivi l'événement avec nous merci
beaucoup aussi à Kevin de m'avoir
accompagné euh pour couvrir cet
événement merci à toi Stéphane c'était
toujours aussi sympa et merci à vous
tous d'avoir interagi dans dans le chat
et c'est vraiment une une compétition
très très rigolote comme d'habitude à à
commenter bien animé avec un match
peut-être aujourd'hui avec un peu plus
d'écart quand même moins spectaculaire
que les deux autres demi-finales qui
avaient été très très chaudes jusqu'au B
oui oui c'est ça c'est ça
donc voilà merci en tout cas à tous pour
répondre rapidement à brebius il y a un
film sur les échecs' le film que je te
conseille c'est le film le prodige en
français euh pound sacrifice en anglais
c'est le film sur la vie de Bobby Fisher
il est sorti il y a quelques années au
cinéma d'ailleurs je l'ai vu en première
et bon c'est un beau film sur l'histoire
des échecs et notamment la vie de Bobby
Fisher Bobby Fisher qui était peut-être
un des meilleurs joueurs de l'histoire
en tout cas donc si
c'est celui un film un peu plus ancien
avec à la recherche de Bobby Fisher
justement oui euh mais c'est sympa aussi
voilà ouais oui oui oui mais il Estel
plus actuel quand même c'est vrai bien
sûr bien sûr complètement c'est pour ça
mais bon après il y a plein de teils sur
les échec voilà voilà donc merci à tous
en tout cas et puis ben moi je vous dis
à bientôt sur bah sur nos chaînes
respectives hein vous savez qu'on a tout
les de une chaîne twitch tous les deux
une chaîne Youtube euh Kevin en plus a
une un site dans lequel il vous donne
aussi des packs vidéos dans cont en tout
cas n'hésitez pas à aller fouiller un
petit peu tout ça et moi je vous dis à
très bientôt en tout cas je sais pas
quand est-ce qu'on se reverra sur FA ça
on verra mais en tout cas venez me voir
sur nos
chaîne puis voilà Kevin bon courage pour
pour ton tournoi qui va commencer
du ça démarre demain à kil
Keny voilà donc c'est un tournoi où où
je crois qu'il est il est il est
apprécié de consommer de consommer de la
bière ouais c'est ça exactement
exactement ça promet d' un tour festif
qui compte pas pour le ho donc voilà
donc du coup on est tranquille et puis
ça va être sympa alors s'il y avait une
caméra dans la salle j'aurais bien
choses bien sûr bien sûr là ça très très
lourd à mon avis qui se passe à Kilkenny
je pense ça reste à Kilkenny ouais vaut
mieux vaut mieuxense je pense que c'est
un peu ça l'idée tout j'imagine bien en
tout cas merci à tous je souhaite une
bonne soirée merci à to et puis à très
très bientôt allez à très bientôt à
bientôt ciao ciao salut